there's no time
[Music]
the time is thirteen o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody it's saturday yeah we're
back
and look sophie's in the comments
she flew home yesterday then i got miss
pookie pants back here trying to
[ __ ] tear the [ __ ] up i know that's
like when you start recording she's just
like yeah
that's crazy the video i'm gonna show
for her in the middle was just like four
minutes of her trying to chew on
everything
yeah she's trying to like chew on all
the [ __ ] cords and [ __ ] like that on
my computer let me move this over here
you're always moving that in front of me
okay
well yeah because i don't want it to
fall off the edge you know what i'm
saying
yeah we still we just don't still kind
of hear me
we don't have like this all sorted out
obviously
i just don't have any [ __ ] room for
sure
yeah i wish we could [ __ ] back this
camera up
like another foot you can't cause
there's a wall there yeah
and that would solve a lot of problems
it would yeah yeah uh michael schaefer
says am i the only one having trouble
hearing i don't
you shouldn't because i mean i can turn
the mic
up but i don't know if that'll be too
loud
is that any better yeah sound check
everybody what's it sound like
yeah because i didn't i didn't change
anything yeah and actually it's weird
because when we were here before
like when we were last time we recorded
the show like when i did the audio
version it was like really really loud
everything was good okay okay well i
turned it up a little bit
all right today's gonna be a fun show
it's gonna be kind of a
variety show a bunch of weird [ __ ]
that's on the internet over the years
yeah like mostly creepy youtube videos
but like whatever
because because i told them it's like
look i have a few classics that i want
to talk about that i thought had like
interesting
or creepy stories behind them um but i
was like you know if you come up with
anything or you've seen anything on
youtube that is
creepy or if anybody in the comments
says anything that they've seen on
youtube that's creepy
and they want to suggest anything uh you
know
you can do that too and we can just talk
about that there used to be a [ __ ] ton
of like fake
ghost videos on there there's still a
ton of fun i got one that actually
it's probably fake i mean obviously fake
but um i thought it was really well done
actually it's a japanese one
they're um i think they got rid of most
of them it used to be that you couldn't
you couldn't even do any research
because it was just nothing but just
thousands and thousands of the same
fakes over and over again
yeah yeah one guy that was like uh
faking poltergeist activity in his house
you know [ __ ] strings and wires
pulling objects yeah i saw that one
multiple times
he's doing and he's getting pretty
complicated with it but having seen the
real phenomenon i was like no that's not
it
you could tell i've seen some kind of
like more subtle ones which i thought
were better
like i saw one earlier today that looked
like it was it looked like a mall food
court i want to say
and it was just like there were people
in the background and i guess it was a
security camera or supposed to look like
a security camera
and then like in the foreground was an
empty table but somebody had
like left all their [ __ ] on like all
their trash
and like one of the napkins went like
like off the table and then like one of
the chairs like moved out like that yeah
and um then i could do that with string
though well yeah i know that but i'm
just saying that if you're gonna fake
it i think it's better to do a fake one
that's more subtle like that because
that to me that seems more realistic
i mean because you've we've seen the one
and everyone's probably seen it but that
one like famous poltergeist one where
it's just like a still camera and it's
like in a kitchen or some kitchen or
dining room
and it's just like there's [ __ ] [ __ ]
flying everywhere it's like you know the
cabinets are opening
like the [ __ ] spoons are all coming
out of the drawer and
i'm like just tone it down a little bit
it's like no one's gonna buy
that that being real all that [ __ ]
happened there was only one of them like
that that i saw one time that
did kind of make me think it was real
a drawer opened up and a bunch of
individual silverware started flying out
and there was
some you know there'd been there's
phenomena in the house nobody lived in
the house
um or you know they'd fled the house
and then you could see the camera itself
started to
shake and make a lot of static yeah
and it was an old you know mid 90s
video video camera it was some
parapsychology department of
some university somewhere was doing it
it's pretty weird and they got a
photograph of a weird shadow
going down a hallway when it got to the
damn door
at the end of the hallway the door
opened oh okay that's
weird well like i said it's i'm sure
like 99.999
of those are fake but it's you know if
you're gonna fake it at least make it
like kind of realistic
yeah the thing the thing about it is
that the shadow that was went down that
one side of the hallway
they couldn't figure out how that was
cast yeah you know what i mean like
it didn't seem like it would be possible
from the from the from the light sources
that were around
yeah unless it was done by the up near
the bulb the bulb itself but it was
daytime
it was weird yeah and i've only found
that one a couple times on youtube
it disappears easily because it has
different names and
it gets moved to the bottom because
people don't know the history behind it
i saw it on
on that program sightings a long time
ago in the 90s yeah
they had a little episode on it well the
problem too was that
i mean there's so many of those on
youtube and there's so many channels
that
are that do like creepiest videos on
youtube like lists and stuff so it's
like they
they get like reposted so many times
like you said with different names
and it's like so it was kind of hard
like i
you know i i wanted to talk about like
some of the sort of like classic creepy
videos that come up like on a lot of
people's lists and [ __ ]
but i was trying to look for some
different ones too and it's like it's
really hard to find them just because
there's so many that are
you know not that good or you know it's
just hard to dig through because there's
so many
and um especially like ones that are
hauntings or poltergeists or [ __ ] like
that and
michael schaefer said if you hear that
girls if you're gonna fake it make it
sound real
[Laughter]
well see that's what i'm saying if
you're gonna make like a poltergeist or
a ghost like make it as realistic as
possible you can't go too over the top
of the [ __ ]
otherwise it's very clearly fake sandra
said the only poultry guy story she
heard
that sounded real was mine and i'm gonna
tell you mine was real
but there are some other ones that i've
that i've read some of the ones
a lot of the ones in the in the book
that jenny wrote unseen hand a lot of
those
sound real to me but i would say
the best one to go to is if it's
probably out of print but it's called
enfield poltergeist
that's a good book it's called this
house is haunted i have it
here i don't think it's out of print
anymore it was for a while but i think
that it
they did like another reprinting of it
when um
the conjuring too came out because i
think that was loosely based on it
yeah it's called this house is haunted
by guy lion playfair
and that's what i saw exactly what's
described in that book right there but
there's a couple
a couple of the witnesses claim to see
things that really they were the only
ones that claimed to see that
and some of the stuff was kind of
iffy like you know the voices that came
out of her
that could be explained by poltergeist
not
in a different way i think that was her
subconscious mind doing that
yeah kind of like tourette's syndrome it
was was doing it
um but you know it's still overall i
think
the stuff that guys saw and the stuff
that
uh what was his name the other the other
uh pair of psycho morris gross morris
gross the stuff that they saw you could
probably pretty much take that to the
bank
and um the cops saw it and newspaper
paper uh reporters saw
just little things like bricks flying
around lego bricks flying around uh
objects being thrown and it came from an
area where there was nobody standing
there you know just
it's furniture being pushed up against
the door it was a lot like mine
a lot like it but that one lasted a lot
longer yeah what 18
months yeah i think it'll be 15 months
yeah i saw a couple of youtube videos
too that actually like i said they were
probably fake but
they actually looked good in the sense
that they were taken supposedly by
security cameras
and they were like in offices so there'd
be like all these like rows of desks and
chairs and stuff and then there'd be
nobody there and then all of a sudden
like the chair would
come out and like there'd be a little
pile of paper and it would go like wow
like off the desk and stuff like that
so i you know even though those are
probably fake too like i said they
i kind of like like those better those
are creepier to me yeah because
a security guard could set that up well
yeah and then erase his
his you know the video of him going in
there and setting it up and another
guy's pulling on the
pulling on fishing line fishing line on
low res [ __ ] video
like yeah you can't see it it disappears
so that's what i mean like you know most
of the poltergeist videos
if not all the poltergeist videos that
are on youtube i think are probably that
yeah you know what i'm saying either you
know because i feel like and it's not
necessarily people necessarily trying to
fake it it might be
somebody doing like an arg or a web
series
based on my observations and you've seen
it too
how do you catch something that fast and
so spontaneous on video you have to have
a camera ready
and it only does it every once in a
while you know and it seems like it
can't move something that you're
directly looking at
yeah i mean you're just sitting there
and all of a sudden something comes out
of your into your field of vision moving
and you can't figure it out i feel like
it's kind of like um you know the the
movie paranormal activity where
your your backstory is that oh we had
some paranormal activity that we didn't
film but then we set up cameras all over
this they'd be
running all the time so we could catch
what was going on because then that way
you have plausible deniability
i think if you set up cameras in my in
my poultry guys house over there
and leave it at lois house or a mammoth
it would do things behind the camera
yeah and it actively foiled whatever you
were trying to do to catch it
it just it just dicks like that yeah
yeah i
kind of kind of had a feeling that if
you were looking right at it
it made it so it couldn't move it or
yeah you know what i mean it was um it's
probably something that quantum physics
you know um what's his name [ __ ]
had a good theory on that not bros but
the other guy
roger pembrose and uh ken bros pam yeah
i don't know the guy's name
what's that guy's name roger what
stewart hammer off stuart hamroff's
website and roger penrose
camrose yeah that's what i said no you
said pembrose
with a bee look at her isn't that
something i'ma drink it
okay you only just started it but you
know
you have to be technically correct
because that's the best kind of
correction
okay whatever so i got you so i got you
well yeah that's what i was doing that's
what i got i was correcting you
[Laughter]
so let's see uh see everybody saying
yeah sandra says i believe your story
time because i know you you're crazy but
you're no wind bag and not stupid
they're talking about
talking about uh the anfield case alex
said eat the good miss talking about
talking about sophie yeah zach says oh
sophie's gone she's in the comments
though
zach saying she went home yesterday
zach's on his way to a party
mirror spock is judging me he's judging
all of us i think
you want to do some uh shout outs yep
just have a couple hiccup him
holy crap already we're only like 10
minutes into well 20 minutes into the
show now because you're already
it's gonna be a good show he's gonna be
like that then
it's gonna be a good show he actually
gave me tonight no saturday night
yesterday's friday he doesn't know what
day it is
seriously we only just started drinking
you guys we haven't snowed we haven't
been drinking all day i promise
yeah this is my this is literally my
first drink right here yeah
fine i mean i poured that [ __ ] though i
got pineapple juice today i poured that
[ __ ] so you better watch out
well i'm not the one that forgot what
day it was am i yeah no i'm not
well i remember what day it was after i
forgot
[Laughter]
i always remember things after i forget
it yeah but yeah so uh
we just got a couple of uh shout outs
wanted to
uh give a big shout out to ken who sent
us some really really cool presents yeah
okay so he sent me this for my for like
a late birthday present he sent us the
hh homes also
but look at that look at that it's a
cell it's a cell from willy wonka
piece from one of the films oh my god i
love it
yeah yeah i cannot like undo that and
hang it up on the wall
sent me two little pops and then we got
two little pop figures
one of which is look at alice cooper
yeah and then another one is lemmy
kilmister
i love this one yeah look at him little
lemmy he's got a little cigarette and
everything yeah
poor lambie died not too long ago i know
everyone does
not have a cancer what are you gonna do
yep what are you gonna do i'll put them
up there with the uh
billy island yeah we just wanted to keep
them by here so we could like show them
on the show
and also want to give a shout out to our
newest patron
logan hey there and also our
previous patron justin has also
increased his support this week so
thank you very much you guys y'all are
super awesome
yeah everybody says yoda is bloody
watching me
um somebody said oh elsa lansdale was
asking about the
indoor rain dude that was don decker
the rain man yeah don decker don decker
i believe that story because
well too many prison guards too many
that warden
you know they saw the phenomenon that's
poltergeist
people think poltergeist is some kind of
outside phenomenon
and the poltergeist focus is generated
it thinks it's out
it's an outside phenomenon too that
deckard is the only one the only guy the
only guy that
that i've heard of that realized that it
was a part of him that was doing it
and he actually could will it into
action
was able to like control it to make it
rain out of nowhere
indoors weird [ __ ] and the cops said
that [ __ ] balls of water
would form in midair and then go
sideways across the room
uh he could will a a water droplet to
hit the warden while he was in his
office [ __ ] hundreds of yards down
the dam
on the other side of the building he
could just
cause water to condense at an amazing
rate
and um what else could what else could
he do that was about it how he would see
visions well he could also i think he
moved like
pots and pans yeah that's right he could
move some things
yeah he also lifted himself off the
ground and
beating himself from himself yeah and
then threw himself to the floor in front
of about three witnesses
uh he also could do it outside of a
familiar area he did it he did it a
little bit in a restaurant in front of a
bunch of witnesses
and he could do it in prison when he
went back to prison um
that's a wild case man and i believe it
just there's just too many damage that's
like one of the weirdest poltergeist
cases ever it's like it's
that one and the one about that old
couple in atlanta that had all the blood
in their house and they couldn't figure
out where it came from
he was he was unique you know because uh
he could
say i'm gonna make it rain i had the
power to make it rain he was using it as
like a
like an evil superpower i tried to get
the poultry guys to move an object by
will you know and it stopped the whole
event
didn't come back to a years later yeah
yeah then it just kind of matured into
things like out of body experiences
um you know like astral projection also
kind of like dreaming true
having weird feelings that certain
things would happen uh
weird synchronicities um
seeing people and recognize them as
being important before i knew who they
were
just weird stuff like that that's what
it's what it is now it it it does
it does um it moved a few objects you
know jenny saw it
you know in recent history but it's just
not as good as it was
yeah it used to be a lot more impressive
but i used to get more scared of it
and i think you have to be scared of it
you was a scared yeah you had to be
scared of it
being scared of it feels it well yeah
because i mean
once you get old and jaded yeah you know
you know your emotions aren't as like up
there
right i think hormones may have
something to do with it too yeah
hormonal intensity
i read a paper about that once a while
back lots of emotion and stuff
yeah that they thought maybe something
had to do with some kind of chemical
reaction yeah
during people's puberty and stuff i
don't think that's necessarily the case
because
you know i've seen some kind of
believable poltergeist cases that didn't
have
uh adolescence involved but you know
probably like 80 90 of them based on
what based on what happened to me in my
research and just
looking at the cases i believe what i
think it is is the emotional volatility
in a kid that is very disciplined and
can hold it in so you're kind of like
you have it corked up like in a bottle
yeah and then
you get hit with frustration and this
thing kind of lashes out the
subconscious kind of lashes out
using some kind of quantum some kind of
a quantum
energy or something and it can move
objects
it does weird things in the environment
and it can do it faster than you can
think about it and it can do it in rooms
that you're not looking in so
there's another part of us in another
dimension that has a
bigger awareness of what's going on
something that's not local
not local to you you know what i mean
it's more like in a general vicinity
yeah because it was down there moving
objects in other rooms and i couldn't
see those rooms
but it would stack things up you know
yeah because that's pretty weird
roger said it's powered by pms yeah it
worked
that would work thank you so you all
should start making it rain for this
show
yeah she you were like you were really
really good at segways
[Laughter]
you know what i mean where's i'm not
good at that
i can't make it rain oh hey ken uh we
already showed your
we already showed your presents yeah so
thank you for those thanks kim
i don't put them up there with the other
rock stars
[Laughter]
see what's going on yeah zach says i
like to call it editable male syndrome
alrighty all right so you want to start
talking about some creepy videos
yeah i'm just listening to what they're
saying about what story
else is talking about some story i don't
know what he's talking about
um she said something about a friend of
hers that was in like a really abusive
relationship and she said like all the
teacups and [ __ ] started flying around
okay so he could do it a bit too
yeah or she could do it oh she could do
it yeah and i noticed that it's
it's um i think intelligence has
something to do with it
you can't be so dumb that you you can't
imagine it happening
but you can't be so smart that you you
could talk yourself out of the
possibility of it happening i think you
have to be
of average intelligence to slightly
above or to to average intelligence
probably slightly above intelligence
to to exceptional intelligence but not
none of this genius stuff i don't think
they can do it
i think they're too too firmly ground uh
uh too firmly planted in the ground
you know what i mean they would say no
that's not imp it's impossible so it
wouldn't happen well and plus people who
are really smart tend to overthink
everything over thanking everybody and i
think that overthinking
is like kind of anathema to that sort of
thing because you have to kind of be
able to like let yourself go and i think
a lot of really smart people there
wasn't any thinking involved
just reacting you know in a bunch of
emotion
and uh and it seems to be that you have
to have
some kind of belief in the possibility
of a paranormal
if you don't have that belief in it you
probably won't do it
yeah you'll probably prevent yourself
from doing it what's weird is how people
react to it
when they see it and they don't believe
in the paranormal they panic and they
run you never see them again
yeah they don't even want to talk about
it after that
so it upsets people that are really
firmly grounded in reality because
it it shatters their presuppositions
about you know
about the universe that you know but i
think it's something i think it's just i
don't
it's paranormal but i think it's
supernatural it's it's something kind of
kind of like electricity yeah
electricity used to be paranormal at one
time they used to think that was some
magical [ __ ]
that you could bring [ __ ] bodies back
to life with it or whatever it came from
the heavens
yes it made light before there was light
bulbs so it seemed to be supernatural
yeah you know and that's completely like
right understandable why people would
think that this is the same thing
at like that it's just something we
science hasn't discovered yet it's gonna
be something in in the realm of like
quantum consciousness
it's gonna be like that yeah you know
based on what i saw you've seen it too
how do you explain that [ __ ] yeah you
know you just can't really explain it
yeah um stomp propaganda just mentioned
local 58 i was actually going to talk
about that a little bit because i only
just like started watching that today
that's like oh
it's like not really an arg it's like a
web series
um and it's really really well done it's
like super creepy so yeah i was like
watching some of that today
as well so i would like recommend people
watch that if they like like creepy
energies or creepy web series that look
like realistic and [ __ ] like that before
i get off the subject though i wanted to
complete
what i was thinking i kind of think that
what i'm talking about what we call
poltergeist
phenomenon there's probably a very good
chance
that highly advanced extraterrestrials
kind of use that kind of
stuff in their science they probably
know all about it probably doesn't shock
them at all
and for all we know they they build
machines that can do that
yeah but you know it's just a part of
some kind of facet of that we haven't
scientifically figured out yet
something theoretical yeah some
scientists somewhere [ __ ] might have
a theory that can explain it but it's
not going to be recognized yet
yeah and how do you build a tool or a
machine to test it
it's gonna be pretty [ __ ] tough yeah
you know fourth jar down says have you
seen the youtube video but the woman who
married michael jackson's ghost
i heard about it but i haven't seen it
yet
i'm trying to think about this i think
we mentioned this before we might
you marry a [ __ ] ghost how do
you prove that you're married and does
he well you don't have to
that's kind of like if you divorce him
does he owe you money yes
well that would be like the whole well i
that would be the whole thing behind the
scheme i would think
right because you marry mike
michael jackson then you say that he
broke up with you and then you sue him
[Laughter]
and then you make his lawyer give you
some of that estate
yeah that's how i was like well they
can't prove that i didn't right
i don't think that's weird
elsa says yikes of all the ghosts she
could marry why him right it's like you
know
they got some freaky ass women out there
that get transfixed with these weird
dudes you know
even up to it including serial killers i
was just gonna say
i just discovered um a creepy youtube
channel i don't know if it's there
anymore it might have been taken down
but it was this girl named lynn
ann or this woman rather and she was
like super obsessed with
uh one of the columbine shooters eric
harris or whatever she had like a mug
with his face on it like a pillow and
all of a sudden
she was like super [ __ ] weird there's
a guy there's a channel called razorfist
you guys
might want to check it out he does a lot
of metal reviews and commentaries i
think he's a good show host
but he had a whole series on michael
jackson okay
and he's done he's a michael jackson fan
he's a heavy metal [ __ ] guy
but you know classic heavy metal but he
loves michael jackson too yeah
and um he was swearing up and down that
michael jackson
was you know was set up by those people
for that pedophile case and he had me
believe in it
against all better judgments i started
to kind of i don't know it's like i
wasn't there and it's like some of his
behavior is so creepy but then
on the other hand he had mental problems
and it's like i don't know i don't i
don't really know where i fall on that
evidently the people that made the
complaint against him and i think there
was
more than one family
but those two families like evidently
had a long history of making complaints
against other people about that kind of
[ __ ] and that it may have been
and that that really what it was he
razorfist thought that maybe he did have
predilection towards that way but he
wasn't really
acting on it it was something kind of
like just a part of his personality
and uh that there were people out there
that [ __ ] saw him for what he was and
we're going to try to suck him in and
get some of that money
yeah i mean that's when you're that rich
and that famous
i mean i imagine you're going to get
like a certain amount of people like
yeah he was he was evidently ripe to be
framed
yeah but that these that the persons
that made the
the accusation that a lot of the [ __ ]
that they claimed didn't turned out not
to be true
and they had a kind of a a history of
making [ __ ] uh
complaints against people that weren't
supported by fact
it's uh i don't know i had to go back
and look at it again it's been several
years since i saw it yeah like i said
i don't know enough about it he may have
been a little funny you know what i'm
talking about
he might have been one of those p words
but i think the ones that were leveling
[Laughter]
but i think the people that leveled the
claims leveled the charges at him were
kind of bogus
yeah you know although like he said he
did kind of leave himself open to that
kind of thing
just because he liked to hang out when
you have a [ __ ]
when you have a [ __ ] whole ferris
wheel and a train
in your backyard when you have an
amusement park in your backyard with a
bunch of little peter
bronze peter pan statues everywhere
of all these little skinny pretty white
boys drinking out of the water and [ __ ]
you know what i mean
all like like like little little little
little gnomes and [ __ ]
you know some shit's up that's a little
spooky don't you think it is a little
spooky
you know i'm not the kind i would never
have
dozens of these little white boys
statues drinking
daintily drinking out of the water you
know with their little shorts on and
like little peter pans
little peter pans everywhere you know
it's
little fairies and stuff you know just
little 10 year old boys everywhere this
shit's [ __ ] suspicious
that's what i'm saying he left himself
over it's just very [ __ ] suspicious
it is suspicious because you would think
you know he was what in his 30s
in his 40s when he died or 50 in his 50s
very early 50s but he spent all that
time just him
and all these little boys right you
would and during his 20s and 30s you
know he was on his own
if you had that kind of money you should
have a palace filled with strippers
in your 20s and 30s you would think a
single man in his 20s and 30s with that
much money he's not
he's going to [ __ ] run wild he's
going to have a whole mansion
filled with strippers and pool girls and
[ __ ] you know what i'm talking about
that's what it's gonna really gonna be
well yeah you would just like you would
just like hire women to like
lay there and delay on your pool so you
can uh you know do coke off you'd have a
whole crew of porn stars just show up
yeah but you have them on the clock
that's what they do
until they get sick of it but you know
get out of my house
all right oh [ __ ] all right so
let's can we get to the topic now yeah
[Laughter]
i've warmed them up
all right so like i said this is a very
freewheeling uh
type of show very free willing topic
this was again this was the topic that
most of the patrons voted on i think
this wasn't even close it was like
the vast majority of votes were for this
so we're going to talk about
some creepy youtube videos and i just
kind of picked random ones that i
thought had kind of interesting stories
behind them
some of them are kind of classic some of
them are maybe less well-known
and of course if tom thinks of anything
too he can
throw in as he usually does so the first
one i want to talk about this is one i
don't know if i'd call it like the
granddaddy of like creepy youtube videos
but it's definitely up there i mean any
self-respecting top 10 list of creepiest
youtube videos ever is probably going to
have this one
on it and this is the classic i feel
fantastic
now this video was actually first
uploaded in
2009 now the name of the user
was creepyblog as far as i am aware
creepy blog never uploaded any other
videos other than this one
and uh if you haven't seen it i'll
probably show some of the videos like
right here just like a little really
little in the middle
um some of them i didn't want to show
because i don't know if i'm going to get
in trouble for [ __ ]
whatever but here's i feel fantastic
right there and as you can see it is a
kind of a robot or an
android or something of that nature
singing a very
weird little song some noodling in the
background some [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that says i feel fantastic
yeah that's it and it's like hey hey hey
and then like there's some other [ __ ]
like later on
the lyrics go more toward like please
leave
and then say like run run run run
now this video like i said was uploaded
in 2009 by a person that apparently
didn't upload any other videos
so it started getting passed around it's
like this really creepy kind of [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] is the story behind
this
now i can't remember what time stamp
it's at
but there's this and like the head and
arms kind of move
and then there's like this just random
shot of like a backyard
and then like a close-up of like some
dirt and sticks and stuff
oh [ __ ] like they buried somebody right
so it's like so the fact that that was
just
in there and i mean this shit's creepy
enough right here but then like the fact
that that was in there as well so kind
of an urban legend i guess
started to spring up about this video
[Music]
that whoever made this video uh they go
by the name john bergeron or bergeron
that perhaps they were a serial killer
and that this was like an android that
they had made
because this android came to be named uh
people found out somebody was named tara
so they're like this is the video the
serial killer made and they killed
somebody named tara and that shot in
there
is like where they buried her and those
are her clothes
and he made an android out of her
because another thing it wasn't just the
shot of the woods see there see right
there it's there's like a shot of a
backyard
and it's like close up and then there's
like [ __ ] like that like why is that
even in there
another weird thing too was that the
description of the video
talked about the um the pygmalion
myth like the greek legend of pygmalion
which is a guy
that which if you don't know which is
about a guy that thought like all real
women were
you know unclean or like not worth it
and so he
wanted to make a perfect woman so he
made one
out of ivory and
i guess aphrodite like felt sorry for
him
and brought the statue to life so
the fact that that was the only
description of that video
and then there was like no other context
for it like
all kind of [ __ ] uh crazy like urban
legends sprung up about that because
like i said it's been up since 2009 so
like 11 years
so you know it went around and around
and then um like i said somebody
investigated and found out that the
person that had created it was
named john bergeron or called themselves
john bergeron
and he got a reputation of being maybe
he's a serial killer
but then somebody kind of dug deeper
down
and then they found out that there was
an old website
um for robot builders called
androidworld.com
and that's where the name john bergeron
came from he was the creator of this
robot
that was called tara and um
he said that he had made it for like a
couple thousand dollars
like but just with spare parts or
whatever and what his
plan was i think or according to this
website
was that he was going to make the
world's
first android pop star
like i guess it was like some kind of
weird thing that he was launching
now apparently he had made five
clips of this android um they were
called
electricity metal version brutal metal
please electricity and brutal one
but no one has ever been able to find
any of those and i'm not really sure
like where the video that everybody's
seen which one that comes from
um there actually was for a time
somebody had uploaded
i believe it was in 2015 there was a
youtuber in russia
and they uploaded like a longer video of
the tara thing and they said oh this is
like
you know one of the full-length ones
like that they had found somewhere but
then for some reason it got taken down
or they took it down or something no
one's been able to find it anymore
so nobody there's been like no activity
on the channel there's been no activity
on this website there's been no activity
under that guy's name or anything like
that since 2006
i guess or you know from on that website
so it's like nobody really knows
why he made the video why there's like
this [ __ ]
shot of like a [ __ ] backyard in it
like that looks like
look where i buried somebody like he was
trying to get caught or something where
did this come from again um it was first
uploaded in 2009
okay although i think the video was made
earlier than that all right yeah because
i think the website information was from
2006 or from earlier than 2006
okay that he had made this and like i
said apparently he
his goal was or so he said was that he
was going to make this android and it
was going to be the firs the world's
first android pop star
so i guess it was like some i don't know
if it was some art project he was doing
or some
i don't know what it was and like i said
that's not that's just kind of the story
behind it nobody really knows
because that guy never liked was it a
mannequin i couldn't really see it that
well
yeah it's a store mannequin well it's um
i think it was a dental mannequin
but he like put machinery in it so that
it would
so that its head would move and its arms
would move and stuff like that so it was
kind of like he called it tara the
android yeah you know what i'm saying
yeah well these guys better get ready
for what's coming because
a friend of ours owns this looking uh
little little bar called mannequins and
he bought three of these damn sex dolls
and he already had one in there you
already had one in it and he put him in
the lingerie and had him standing up
there like they were the strippers
on the stripper pole and the crowd's
reaction to these things is [ __ ]
amazing i mean people go in and grope
these things well obviously girls come
in and grope these things
it's [ __ ] weird but uh
it's it's amazing you know what i mean
just for like for like
a thousand dollars of what kind of doll
that'll get you yeah
well the thousand dollar ones i guess
you say they look all right i mean you
know
they're still a little uncanny valley
but
they say they got like two thousand
dollar three thousand dollar ones that
the technology is getting a lot better
before you know it those things are
going to be moving and walking and
talking
and then no one's going to want them
because they're like well [ __ ] i'll just
get a real woman for that
well they'll buy them goodbye a guy buys
a car or a motorcycle
yeah that [ __ ] will be [ __ ] wireless
and talking to the internet 5g
and then they'll realize that they could
do work and then what's that
once that happens we're all out of a job
man it's gonna be like that [ __ ]
movie ai well people are buying [ __ ]
robots and
you send the robot to do your job and
then yeah that's going to be
that's that's seriously going to upset
the [ __ ] economy
yeah well what are you going to do yeah
what's going to happen when you can get
a better husband or a better wife you
just buy one
and it's a robot yeah human race will
die out human race will die out nobody
maybe every but maybe everyone will be
much happier
if they're planning that the [ __ ]
who's that
powerful oligarchs and [ __ ] that are
running the world are like you know we
got to reduce the population we
invented these people we we created
these people to work in our factories
during the baby boom
and uh factory we don't need them
anymore we're going to replace them with
robots anyway let's just give them all
robots
like they did in blade runner you know
give them yeah give them replicants
to entice them to do stuff like leave
leave and go off world well they just do
it they
entice you not to have children they
give you a [ __ ] robot
yep and you don't know the difference or
it's it's
for a lot of these second installs be
better than what they could get
better than the woman they could get
well that's what i mean it's like in a
lot of ways it might be better
yes the first time leave real women
alone exactly
yeah win-win yeah
we don't have their [ __ ] well they
say coming up and [ __ ] bothering me
they said like eighty percent of the
women are fighting over the top ten
percent of the men anyway
well i don't know if it's that severe
but yeah that's that's i heard some
pretty
severe statistics yeah but where'd those
statistics come from
i don't know it's just they're just out
there yeah look at it again you pull
them out of your butt
it's kind of immediately no you know how
do i pull them out about that
i think that might be true for japan i
mean they got a [ __ ] huge [ __ ] uh
sink everybody's single in japan and
then you gotta be perfect to get a
significant other
yeah that's what they say well people
living in them little rooms
i guess yeah i don't know what you want
me to do about it
you're not having any replacement
population
yeah oracle says the in cells keep
thinking that real women will be jealous
of the robots and speaking is a real
woman i think the incels are welcome to
them
that's gonna happen the in sales would
be happy to get that robot they'll be
talking they'll be trading robots with
each other they'll be [ __ ] buying
and like i said they'll be leaving real
women alone so that'll make us happy
they'll say this they'll just go shut up
and go with their
like i'm through with this old one i'm
gonna go get the next model
it's better than this one and then they
[ __ ] sell that one they they give
they give that one to hand me downs to
somebody else
and buy a bigger better model more
realistic
i bet you they're gonna be kind of doing
that kind of [ __ ] the technology's there
i forgot i didn't put my ticker back on
oh yeah put the ticket back
after my some spooky [ __ ] just talk
about robots all right i'm off a robot
kick
now kanavasan says is the volume too low
i just turned the volume up why does my
volume keep
going back down because i haven't i
don't touch it ghost
i maybe it is there is a what's that red
x
that's that's for this okay that's for
the webcam okay i just pointed everybody
that was like 3d that's 3d moment
you see i got to get on in on this
[ __ ] program
you got it so i know how to use it well
yeah
well i mean it's easy to use once well
it's easy once you have everything
okay front loaded all right you know
what i mean because i already have all
the clips and everything like that in
there
i have to go in there and put everything
in alex says the sound is great
everybody some people say it sounds good
okay maybe it's just like people's
youtube or something because i haven't i
really haven't touched it
you know since the last time and i think
like the last time that i did the audio
it was like actually really loud
it's michael jackson's ghost turning the
volume down
god damn it yeah [ __ ] off
get the hell out of my house all right
starting to get some of that alcohol in
my system
oh yeah yeah it's starting to get in
there oh my goodness yeah you've
really uh drunk quite a bit there we
have we're only like 45 minutes in
i'm ready though i'm ready 45 minutes
this body is ready i'm ready i'm ready
all right so the next one i want to talk
about another classic
uh youtube video that comes up on a lot
of creepy youtube videos
is sad satan let's see
let's show a little bit of this this is
kind of like
this one i'm not sure like um i can't
remember where i got this one from
because this this is one of the videos
that gets like passed around a lot
so this actually is supposedly
uh a video game that originated from the
deep web
now this was first um premiered
in june of 2015
and it was on a gaming channel that was
called obscure horror corner now this
was like not a massive channel or
anything like that but they uploaded
this
which ostensibly was a playthrough
of this game called sad satan which i
believe was um
named after like the backwards masking
in that led zeppelin
song you know what i mean yeah um so
so they uploaded it and supposed to be
like a playthrough now
no one is entirely sure like where this
game came from if it really did come
from the deep web or whatever
so it's basically just if you walk
through it
it's just kind of like a maze and it's
just like
all these dark colors and there's kind
of like buzzy looking and everything
and then it's just kind of like you know
changes in lighting [ __ ] like that
there's kind of some flashes of
photographs um some of the photographs
in there and some of the references in
it
are to like um like some
sexual assault like some rapists like
pictures of rapists
um the assassination of john kennedy
stuff like that sort of like kind of
like flashing these images
now they supposedly the website kotaku
the gaming uh blog gaming website
they actually um got an interview with a
person who was ostensibly the owner of
this channel
the obscure water channel that i
mentioned earlier
and this person said that
they had downloaded this game from
tor which is one of the
[Music]
and so he's saying that he didn't create
it he was just saying i found it
somewhere
and it was like there was this user
named zk
and they were the ones that like pointed
me toward it and then i downloaded it
from the deep web
now then a little bit later
there was another version of the game
and it was uploaded
to 4chan and this was uploaded by
somebody claiming to be zk who was
either the original creator of the game
ostensibly or was the person that had
pointed this obscure horror corner
channel toward it
and now this version of the game um
was actually seemed like it was plagued
with malware like it had all kind of
[ __ ] it was like making people's
computers crash
um and then if you could actually get
into it and like play it without your
computer [ __ ] up
um they actually saw
like [ __ ] like child porn and all this
kind of crap so like turning up in there
and like i said it was like really like
[ __ ] up people's hard drives and [ __ ]
like that
so again nobody really knows where this
game came from who made this game
where you know what its origin was was
that really the original version that
how this child porn and like
you know footage of murders in it and
[ __ ] like that
so like all of this like kind of urban
legend [ __ ] like sprung up around it
now i was reading this article about sad
satan and i kind of like about the
history of it and um
they're kind of they're like okay well
there's at this stage it looks like
there's like three possibilities
um you know possibility one being that
obscure horror corner
um that they didn't make the game that
they actually did find this on the deep
web just like they said they did
and that the person who posted the child
porn version on 4chan was zk
either the person who created it or the
person who found it on the deep web
um or they said a guy who runs obscure
horror channel
the who was interviewed by kotaku
back in 2015 that he was the one that
created it and was just trying to like
build up a mystique around it maybe um
so he's saying that he got it from
somewhere else because that's a very
common thing to do with
these types of things like args and
stuff like that if you want to
imbue your [ __ ] with mystery you never
say you made it you always say like
someone gave it to you or someone mailed
it to you
anonymously or you found it someplace or
something like that because that makes
it a lot more mysterious
because nobody knows where it came from
so it's possible that the guy that owned
that youtube channel
was the one that actually made it um and
there's also the possibility that
the original game which like i said
isn't really all that exciting is
basically
when the you know just like a guy
walking around a maze pretty much
uh you know a pov of somebody walking on
a maze with
every now and then like flashes of kind
of like
you know rapists and murders and [ __ ]
like that but it didn't have like all
the child porn and all the
more graphic content in it so it could
be that somebody just
downloaded the initial gameplay and
added the child porn to it later on
and then uploaded it saying it was the
original version so they could like
add another layer of [ __ ] to it i guess
because like i said
you say something was found on the deep
web
and people are going to flock to it and
like put it all over youtube and be like
what is this
it's so mysterious and everything
because people love that kind of [ __ ]
right
so i feel like that's kind of where i
kind of feel like the third possibility
is
the more because i this game it doesn't
look like
it was first posted in 2015 right but it
doesn't look like
a game from that time period it looks
old so
i feel like it's maybe just maybe an old
game somebody found it and then somebody
said oh i'm going to add like all this
[ __ ] child porn to it
i don't even know if it was originally
called sad satan or maybe somebody just
called it that
just to make it seem kind of creepy but
the creepy thing about this is that no
one really knows
where it came from or what its original
form was
why somebody made it do you have a
picture of the game it's going right
there
let me see it's just going right there
this is like
i mean i can start it over if you want
but i don't think i can
so what is that an interior shot of
something
yeah it's like a maze it's like a maze
yeah
i mean this is how would child porn be
it would be child porn to be on the
walls
yeah i think it's on the walls i haven't
seen the shop version obviously but it's
like
somebody just decided well because
earlier if you saw earlier there were
like some flashes on the walls and there
were like photographs but that was like
you know
like a photo of the jfk assassination
and stuff like that so i think somebody
like went through there and inserted
like child porn into it i don't know if
the original game had child porn and
then somebody stripped it out and did
like a clean version or if it was the
other way around
there actually doesn't like there's much
to it that's what i mean it's like
that's what's but i think what's creepy
about it is like the back story about it
right that's what i'm saying that's why
i picked some of these videos because a
lot of videos that i s
that i saw like on a lot of these lists
were
tom has been running for 10 minutes i
can't see that you're
[Music]
you're looking at the screen
well yeah that probably is all right so
let me go back to
my ticker go back to my tickers yeah so
like i said the creepy thing about that
one is just there
some of the some of these videos like i
said the stories behind them
make them creepier because a lot of
videos that i thought were like really
cool or really creepy
weren't real and weren't like you know
they were either args or they were web
series or they were like an
art project and they were creepy but
it's like they weren't
trying to make it seem like oh this is a
real poltergeist thing or this is a real
this that the other
it's a real serial killer or whatever
they were just trying to like make it
they were trying to make it realistic
but in in the way that a found footage
movie is realistic you know what i'm
saying
although i will say that i didn't really
want to get into
too much of just like horror short films
because there's a lot of really good
ones
on youtube but um some of the ones that
i thought were really good
and one that people did think was real
for a long time i think it was called no
through road
and it was these three or four british
guys
and they were basically it was like a
found footage and they were driving
around
and they kept they they kept going
through i think it was like a tunnel
but they kept every time they went
through the tunnel they would like loop
back around to the same place again
and so it was kind of like they were all
freaking out because they didn't know
where they were and they were lost and
like their gps like went
haywire and all the kind of [ __ ] like
bavarium well yeah it was kind of like
that but it came out like a while back i
don't remember what it was
and like for a while that got passed
around and then like they got attacked
by this like really creepy looking
like dude like in a weird mask or
whatever
and then like he beats the [ __ ] out of
the guy in the face like with the camera
like at the end and like it was really
good it was really well done
but um i think for a little while that
got passed around as a real video but
actually it was a found footage
movie and now you can kind of find it
and that's that reminded me too like
when i was watching it
is that um on some
like paranormal channels or like cryptid
channels and stuff
i've seen a video of like look at this
[ __ ] creepy ass you know creature
that ran across the road
and they show this creature going across
the road like at night in front of a car
and like his little knees and legs are
on backwards and everything
and i said that's from extra that movie
from the 80s you know what i mean you
remember that british uh
that british horror movie sci-fi [ __ ]
extra yeah i remember that it was good
um they had that one scene where that
really creepy like
critter like with the backwards legs
like runs across the
road in front of that car and for a long
time people have been
taking that clip out of that movie and
putting it up on youtube as a real
cryptid sighting because not many people
have seen that movie so i guess a lot of
people didn't recognize it
yeah and another thing that happens too
is that
i even saw one video that somebody had
posted that had bits of
like you know this guy in the mask and
with the big mouth and he's like sitting
in the corner like shaking and all this
stuff is coming out i remember that and
i'm like that's from
begotten that was in 1991 yeah uh movie
by uh e elias marge or however you
pronounce his last name he's the same
guy that made shadow of the vampire
uh with willem dafoe have you seen that
but uh black and white right yeah he
made a movie in 1991 that
looked like an old silent film yeah and
it's like it's really good i watched it
on youtube it's like
it's really really uh creepy and really
nightmarish um
it's kind of like all symbolic you know
it's like kind of a i don't even know if
it's like kind of a biblical story or
it's kind of like a
like he's supposed to be god and he's
like if all his bowels are coming out
and all i don't know i don't remember
i think he's just meant to trip you up
it is kind of trippy
i mean it's long it's like it's it's
like a feature film it's not like a
short film
but i've i've seen like clips of that
taken out too and like taken out of
context
and like put in like creepiest videos
and stuff like that and i'm like oh i've
seen that movie but yeah
now this one i want to talk about i
don't know if this one's real or not but
this is
um this is super creepy so this was
put up um i don't remember how
maybe 2011 i want to say maybe it was
earlier
but it was this guy named uh dj jeff
joey def joey dj jeff i want to say like
in the [ __ ] gt jazzy jeff and the
fresh prince
or whatever that's why i want to keep i
know that's why i wanted to keep saying
that
dating yourself i know dj joey
yeah and he put up this video and you're
gonna love the title of this
my dead great-grandma's coffin in my own
backyard
now the story behind it
[Music]
in sign language apparently the story
behind this
is that i don't know if so
the cemetery where his great-grandmother
was buried apparently
uh was closing which okay
and um they didn't know like i guess he
couldn't afford to have her move to
another cemetery or there was some issue
there
so he just decided he was gonna put his
great-grandma's
coffin in his backyard and just like
keep it there i don't know what he was
planning to do with it subsequently
but you know that's creepy but it's not
really that creepy but then
he makes this video for whatever reason
and you will see in a little while he's
like let's open it up and like
look at her in there so he goes and he
opens
up he opens her up and then um
he does uh something else also which i
don't really want to spoil it
did he kiss her
and i don't know if it's i mean it looks
like a real test
you're not going to show it but it is
shown it is showing it's like he's
he's not going to show it's not going to
show us that it's right there
she has an old man voice to imitate me
eat this
it's not the age it's that you sound
like an old person like you're always
like clueless
what's going on where is it
what's happening you sound like that
like you remind me of that old guy that
was like in the movies behind us like
what's going on who's this now
[ __ ] all this man did he open it i'm
looking now he's opening it up he's
talking about it he's talking about it
he's gonna open it up
it's like why i don't understand like
and i i looked behind i was like what is
the story behind this and there
every single story behind it says well
you know the cemetery was closing and he
needed someplace to put his
great-grandma
and put his great-grandma's coffin which
i'm like okay fine
but that doesn't mean like keep the
coffin in the backyard
which okay look at that but i don't know
look
back in the 70s and early 80s he had a
puka shell necklace
but he's like showing the coffin like
he's all proud of it and stuff
and then like you know which okay neat
but then he's like i don't know like i
get
i get it where you'd be like well maybe
the curiosity would kind of get you so
let's see what it looks like inside
but it's like so i can i can sort of
understand that
up to that point but then like later yep
there there you go there she is
she's there in the coffin
yeah hey grandma you was able to open
that up
yeah i thought that would be would have
been see i don't like i said this
might be fake but i don't you know i
don't know usually when they vary
something like that they
almost they see a chef
this is
that's what i'm saying the hair is the
one thing that's making it yes
[Laughter]
i don't even know if this dude has like
made any other videos or not i forgot to
check
but it's like this one is like really
really famous it's been viewed like
millions of times
a lot of problems in this story
[Laughter]
i don't think they'd let you bury
anybody in your backyard especially well
i don't know what
what country is this i don't even know
in the city limits
all right now those inbreds the inbred
family they had they had relatives
buried out the front yard
but they were they were wards of the
state you know what i mean they're up in
appalachia
you know [ __ ] it doesn't matter if you
bury somebody
on the side of the road in appalachia
nothing's ever going to build that be
built there after you're dead
and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] routes away
and then i look at this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
okay i've seen them take caskets
and then bury them yeah they usually
have that [ __ ] covered up
in like cement and spackle it's totally
sealed you can't open it up
yeah once you know what i mean after the
service is over
they seal the whole thing up like it's
in a block of concrete almost yeah
and then it's buried at least here in
the united states yeah you can't just
open it
pepper says his dead great grandma gets
credit for being in the video
yeah she was in the credits at the end
and here's the thing she was the star
that wasn't sealed ground water and
everything would have got in it
yeah like i said i don't know where
where this was from
it's not real um oh it said i just found
out it was originally posted in
october of 2010 okay so it's 10 years
old
but i don't really yeah so i don't know
like i said it looked kind of realistic
but then
the hair was kind of like hmm i was kind
of like why would you kiss your
great-grandma i mean why would you kiss
your great-grandma in the mouth while
she was alive yeah much less when she
was dead
he's just trying to freak you out and uh
that was some kind of a that was just
some kind of a
of a of a prosthetic
you know like something from a movie you
know what i mean
it was a fake dead body you know what it
kind of reminded me of with the hair
sticking up like that it kind of
reminded me of one of the um
bodies from poltergeist yeah you know
what i mean
because wasn't there one point in that
where there was like a body and it was
like hair was sticking out how are you
like that how long had he said she'd
been buried
oh i don't know i couldn't see like the
little bitty
because i've seen real coffins opened up
after people have been buried for a
couple decades
it's nasty in there it's dirty yeah it's
a bunch of stains yeah i mean because
you [ __ ] rot
yeah yeah you know it doesn't look like
it looks like it it looks like it looks
very damp and wet in there soupy soupy
yeah
because dead bodies they're beef
everything just leaks yeah lots of
stains
lots of stains and all the cloth gets
eaten up because there's bacteria that
starts eating on all the cloth
and everything it just it doesn't look
that nice yeah and the thing is
her body looked mummified which would
imply that she'd been in there a long
time but the
coffins still look nice and the clothes
still yeah it's not i mean i have seen
real bodies that still
looked okay yeah high altitude
low temperature but yeah it depends on
the climate and like i said i don't know
where that guy is from
or where that video came from so it's
like i'm not really sure yes he could
live somewhere where it's not super damp
yeah
and you know the body didn't rot i saw
him i saw the mexicans looking at a damn
they brought a mexican girl down from
some mountains somewhere she had been
ritually sacrificed
yeah i've seen it yeah her hair was all
braided and she just looked fresh as
[ __ ]
just fresh as hell it looked like a 16
year old girl sitting there she'd been
up there for about four or five hundred
years
yeah but very high altitude thin thin
atmosphere real quick
yeah because i think it might have been
at these mountains i i i can't remember
my
i don't know maybe kanavasan might know
because preservation you need dryness
yeah everything you need no humidity
very dry very cold no insects or
anything up there and she was just kind
of like
kind of like uh dry frozen yeah
like freeze-dried yes good way to put it
freeze-dried but she looked
her hair looked normal fine braids
yeah long braids well yeah i've seen
like thousands of year old mummies
that had like hair that still looked
almost yeah if you saw her from the side
or the back you'd think she was just
asleep
you know and you look at the face and
she's pretty dried a little dried up
but she still looked fresh like she'd
only like
maybe like a week old yeah you know
didn't didn't look like an ancient dead
body
yikes it's a trip man it is pretty
creepy
all right so uh let's see what else we
got let's talk about
the lost man in the paris catacombs
video
this is another one that comes up a lot
on many many like creepy videos list
let's put it up here and get it going
it's very bizarre this is not the whole
entire thing because
but apparently the story is put in the
direction so
yeah he stops to photograph
um
so basically he's filming what he's
seeing very deep inside the catacombs
[Music]
um
exclusively these bits of like camcorder
footage that you're seeing this is
basically like
a flash we hear his breathing get louder
and louder
uh something was scary he's frightened
he's frightened
there we go it doesn't really matter
anyone's saying it anyway on the video
it's just kind of like goes through the
catacombs
so what happens in this is supposedly
was filmed
by somebody who was going
through the paris catacombs which as
most people know is like
there's like six million dead bodies of
skeletons it's like all these like
little tunnels it's very easy to get
lost you're technically not really
supposed to go down in there
because they go down in there anyway
they go down in there anyway but you
technically you're not really supposed
to
actually there's a really good horror
movie i think it's on
netflix maybe or shutter called as above
so below
which uh i believe they actually did let
them film
in the paris catacombs which i think is
the only horror film that was allowed to
do that
and they think that maybe they got the
idea from that particular video because
it was like very
popular so evidently this guy
had gone uh through the paris catacombs
and was exploring them like back in the
1990s
and then just like in the [ __ ] blair
witch project and every other found
footage movie
uh he disappeared down there and then
later on somebody else found
his footage and they you know
so the guy is like kind of going through
the catacombs and he's like getting
really disoriented
and seems like he's getting lost and
then
he um then at the end of it like he
falls over and there's like a splash
like i don't know if they
implied that like something came to get
him or if it's like some kind of [ __ ]
like that
or if he just got lost in there and like
couldn't get out
which like i said that is like a pretty
real
thing that could happen which is why
they don't really let you run around
down there because
i guess over the years there's just it's
just become
so such a labyrinth and it kind of goes
up and down like all these different
levels there's like all these different
entrances to it and most of them are
blocked off
but it's like if you just keep going
around this one and then you go down
that one place and then you like you
can't
get up again suddenly and then you're
just like stuck down there and they
never [ __ ] find your ass
we did a show early on about underground
stuff yeah
i'm totally fascinated by me too
underground stuff that's been
underground people and forgotten uh just
saw something recently that
there are um abandoned subway systems
and tunnels
yeah underneath boston you know and i
lived in boston area
and some of them are forgotten nobody's
been in them and for hundreds of years
yeah not only were they sealed but they
were forgotten where they were
and evidently uh recently somebody went
down and wanted it looked brand new it
was like something from the 1880s
had been sealed up but it was still it's
still there like it was ready for use
yeah weird huh that is weird yeah
and then if anybody in the audience can
help me remember
where this was i'm going to remind you
guys again i saw a program
i wanted like the history channel or
something this must have been
[ __ ] 25 years ago maybe now
yeah maybe about 20 years ago no not
that but 15 years ago probably
um there was a mining there was a mine
and i think it was some kind of like a
[ __ ] bauxite mine or a salt mine or
something
and i think it was somewhere around new
orleans or underneath
or the entrance to it was somewhere in
louisiana and it went
i think under the gulf of mexico
stretched way out in there there was
bauxite
but it's abandoned now you know they
they uh
built it in the early 1900s and it ran
all the way up until like the 1950s
and then it got shut down and they went
into it recently
and there's a whole like 1960s or 1950s
town
still it's still underground and it's
[ __ ] weird as hell man there's all
these apartment buildings and a downtown
with
[ __ ] stop lights and stop signs
and parking part you know like a parking
garage or
or what not what do you call them
parking spaces and [ __ ] you know what i
mean
yeah and garages and [ __ ]
and it looks like you're outside it's
got street lights and everything
but you're in a [ __ ] cave you can't
see that
you can't see the uh the roof yeah it's
hundreds of miles
or hundreds hundreds hundreds of feet
to the roof you know and had tunnels
going everywhere with roads in them you
know so they could go to other parts of
the mine
and all the miners lived in that town
with their families
and you know they'd stay in there you
know several months at a time and then
go up to the surface
and these guys were looking at it all
and going into those old apartments and
there's still
calendars and beds made you know like
they were going to come
like they were coming right back you
know and
it was just a trip to look at this thing
it's an entire town in
total darkness underneath the ground
yeah creepy as [ __ ]
that's pretty creepy imagine if somebody
abducted you and took you down there
blindfolded and you didn't know where
you were and you woke up you thought you
were blind
and you were just walking around inside
that old town and the cars are still
there and everything
yeah remember you tell them it's like
and we've looked around for that and i
couldn't like we couldn't find
it we did because you saw it on a show
right like on the travel channel
you're walking outside the parking lot
you know what the [ __ ] big old
flashlights
you can see cars parked there and all
the tires are rotted it's just sitting
on its rims you know
covered in a thick [ __ ] layer of dirt
and you know there's damn like 1950s era
you know [ __ ] street lamps and lights
like over the parking lot
and there's just cars in there and just
towns and shops and everything and
i can't find it yeah i think it was box
site
box site yeah because i remember us
doing like a lot of google searches like
looking for that [ __ ] again and we
couldn't find it
it was a whole underground town and
if i remember correctly it was a it was
something that was used in
making aluminum and i think that's
bauxite i think it's bauxite
yeah because they showed a couple
different ones
but uh somebody could help me remember
what that was if they if they remember
it was [ __ ] spooky i want to see it
again
yeah they went into those apartments and
it was just like in a tomb
just apartment after apartment after
apartment perfectly preserved
with [ __ ] calendars and the beds made
and dishes
and everything you know and [ __ ] in
total darkness well that's what every
time we see
like because you watch a lot of like
urban exploration channels yeah
and to me the creepier ones are ones
where the [ __ ] is like
untouched yeah it's untouched like you
know because obviously most abandoned
places have had like people going and
they're squatting in there like
teenagers go in there like smoke weed or
whatever and they like spray paint all
over the walls and break stuff
but ones where like especially those
ones like those mansions that are like
way out in the woods and they just got
abandoned like
i don't know if the people that live
there died or whatever but it's like all
the [ __ ] is like
still there it's all still there like
all the furniture is still there nothing
really looks all that bad
what's weird is some of those [ __ ]
abandoned mansions
there hasn't been anybody in them in 20
years and all the stuff's still in there
and it's in disarray you can see people
maybe have rummaged through it
but no real damage you could live in it
yeah it's [ __ ]
yeah because some of those mansions i've
seen on there i'm like i could live in
that
yeah it's like that looks uh pretty
pretty livable
actually a couple of those matches they
showed were modern mansions like you
know from
this era of architecture big glass walls
everything nobody's been in them since
2000
yeah and some bank owns it which doesn't
seem like that long ago it doesn't seem
that long that's 20 years
and there's like there's stuff in them
or you know furniture in there and it
looks like you're in a nice hotel yeah
that's here in florida some of that
stuff
yeah i would imagine it's [ __ ] hot as
hell in there
uh well yeah i wouldn't li i wouldn't
want to live in florida without
ac and honestly abandoned places in
florida
don't usually last all that long because
the humidity
i mean you're going to get the humidity
everything's as soon as the air
conditioning goes off mold's going to
start growing on everything
and also termites are going to start
eating everything so
and um vines are going to grow over
everything like yeah
it's just the whole floor is going to be
covered with like grass and vines and
crap
and there'll be bugs everywhere in it
and [ __ ]
you know what i mean and as soon as it
rains like you know it'll get all damp
the [ __ ] roof will fall in and
[ __ ] like that no they're talking about
the that salt mine in portland no it's
not that
yeah i've seen pictures of that i think
we talked about that on that show we
might have
no because that's super cool looking i
think the entrance to this thing
was somewhere around louisiana and then
you had
you had you had to go down into a big
old [ __ ] elevator
and uh that was somewhere in louisiana
and then you had to get in a damn road
and the mine had
been working on the mine for about a
hundred years back in the 1800s is when
they started
and then the mine went under if i think
it was the gulf of mexico
so i think that town was underneath the
ocean in the gulf of mexico imagine that
[ __ ]
that's cool or at least some of it was
that some of the tunnels were going out
there i don't remember i would not mind
living underground
not one bit they were in perpetual
darkness
and um you know the town the
the company the the the mining company
ran that time
[ __ ] it's it was spooky as [ __ ] i'd
like to see it again
but um i remember seeing some show
i don't know it might have been a series
like a while back about people that
lived
underground like they built houses in
caves or like you know they dug out
houses and [ __ ] and i remember there was
one in
i think it was in australia somewhere in
new zealand i want to say
and like it was actually really really
nice like it wasn't super far
underground they just kind of like dug
out underground and like made
and they like carved like furniture some
of like bookshelves and [ __ ] like that
like out of the walls because i guess
the rock was
fairly soft and it was like really
really nice i thought it was really nice
and cozy i'm like i totally live in that
i'm not weirded out by like living
underground that doesn't bother me
getting back to stealing an abandoned
florida mansion
which would be a sound like a good idea
but think about it
you'd have to get that thing reconnected
to the some of that [ __ ] had power going
to it
yeah which that's quite surprising yeah
um because if you turned on the ac
imagine the mansions that size is
probably close to 600 bucks a month just
in air conditioning costs
in florida during the summer you think
they would they would you think that
they would notice
that power drain maybe not
yeah that's the thing it's like maybe
it's some of those mansions had power
yeah and so well i mean like maybe one
house they wouldn't really notice
because
i mean in the grand scheme of things
it's not really gonna if you moved into
it you'd have to turn the air
conditioning on we live in florida you
cannot survive without air conditioning
that's what i mean a house would rot
without it yeah your house is just going
to be one big [ __ ] mold
one big ball like in after one summer
yeah everything's going to be covered
with mold so i assume the banks
turn make sure maybe there must be some
kind of caretaker they've got to make
sure
they make sure the ac is on but
in the comments section when their guys
were talking about those mansions
they were in the real estate business
and they said that those mansions are
worthless
yeah because the mansion market
evidently is flooded
a person who has money for a mansion
wants their own [ __ ] mansion built
from [ __ ] scratch
well yeah you want it the way you want
it if you have the money why would you
buy some i mean unless you were like
super super into like a particular like
old styler you liked
yeah old antique things they want new
mansions now and they want them [ __ ]
custom ordered and evidently the
mansions
that we're looking at that are abandoned
are not great quality in terms of
[ __ ]
the construction yeah and for the amount
of money it takes to buy it and then
bring it back
up to your [ __ ] standards you could
just have a whole new mansion built
brand new yeah so they don't sell they
sit there on the market for [ __ ]
decades
and i guess the banks use them as
collateral
i guess probably i don't know i don't
know what they do with them and i guess
i don't know if they have caretakers uh
it seems like people can just walk into
them
well yeah because all those urban
exploration channels it's like they just
go into them they just go into them and
they and there's got to be like
you know they have a network because
they all know where they are because
they don't say where they are on the
channels because they don't want people
running around in there what i thought
would be a good scam is just to move in
there
and just start fixing [ __ ] up and make
it look like you own it
and if somebody asks you any questions
there's i'm the caretaker
well that's what i mean it's like here
you might be able to get away with that
for a long time if it was like kind of
remote and no one came by there to check
on it and if the bank ever showed up so
what are you doing here says i'm the
caretaker i don't own it i'm the
caretaker
you're the caretaker says yeah the bank
put me here as the caretaker who are you
with i'm with the bankers and we're on
the same team
is not my house this is your house i bet
you you can get away with it for a long
long time if a house could sit there for
[ __ ] 20 years abandoned
that means you can be in it for another
20 years without anybody you could have
been in it that whole 20 years
that see that's what makes me angry is
that see i wish i had moved into it like
20 years ago i could have lived
there for 20 years for free
i assume somebody comes checks on it but
what what kind of there's no skin off
that person's nose if you're keep taking
care of the house
that's what i mean it's like why would
they care yeah you go like i'm taking
care of it it's like you're not hurting
anything right you know
right you're actually keeping it from
falling down right
you're maintaining it it's like all they
can get you on is trespassing
and it's like right right i change all
the [ __ ] locks
yeah well yeah and then when he shows up
give him the key
yeah and the bank man shows up so here's
the new key yeah we mean there's a new
key oh no
the bank changed it out you didn't know
i'm the caretaker i pulled the axle
foley on it
just like axel foley yeah somebody just
said didn't axel fully do that
here it is yeah yeah it's like something
he would do
well yeah and like i said i don't see
why i mean unless they really wanted to
be [ __ ] about it or unless they
there might be some kind of issue with
um you know liability or something like
that like they might get in trouble if
somebody gets hurt on the property or
blah blah
but other than that i can't really see
why anyone would even
one notice that you were in there if you
weren't calling attention to yourself
and two even if they did know and you
were
fixing up the place then why would they
care you can't they're talking about
centralia you can't live in centralia
though
no centralia has a bunch of noxious
gases and there's no power
and uh there's no water so you can't
live there
dan bell did a good video about that
there's been a couple of good videos
done
about uh centralia that's a weird ass
place yeah and every house and there's
an old [ __ ] dilapidated 1950s era
white trash [ __ ] house now
there's no nice tiles no nice houses in
centralia
it looks like fallout like fallout 4.
yeah
can't you don't want to live there it's
like yeah but it's it's a weird place to
go because it's just like so
eerie there's a badass resort here in
florida you can look it up i think
one of the uh urban exploration one just
go look at abandoned florida resort
it's in pristine condition george bush
stayed in it during the 911 thing he was
secretly hiding out in there
and it's a huge resort in real good
condition which
still has power and it has ac window
units
you could move in there and there
there's pit houses because some of the
buildings are like 20 stories to all
you could move into the penthouse there
and probably stay there for years and
nobody realize that you're in there
see i need to look into that yeah i
don't have to like pay for that
[ __ ] lex luthor would do see that's what
i'm saying yeah that's some super
villain [ __ ]
super villains yeah like think how much
money you could save yeah
on rent living in a [ __ ] penthouse
and an abandoned resort yeah florida
resort
like as long as it still had power
because the weird thing is that a lot of
those
abandoned places an alarming amount of
them still have power
yeah yeah and it's been abandoned for 20
years
which like i said i guess it just must
not be enough of a drain for anyone to
notice or everybody forgot that it was
still
and it doesn't really like mark on the
[ __ ] yeah doesn't even like
you know tip the needle because they
have so many other residences and
businesses
people in the conversation from germany
and other places in europe and
everything
america [ __ ] our state is our states
are the size of a european country and
there's enough empty space in our
population density is very low we only
have high population
density around urban areas of cities you
know
la new york you literally can just leave
you can just leave a house and it'll
stay there for [ __ ] decades
kind of untouched when you think and
like i said like pretty soon like all
the [ __ ] bushes will grow over there
yeah but we all just forgot that it was
there
yeah i saw one of those in mississippi
look like a big old thicket
[ __ ] was going through it there's a
[ __ ] old victorian
[ __ ] house there what was left of it
i love that though i love i love that
yeah that that's just like so creepy to
me that you can just be like
going through the woods and like all of
a sudden there's a house yeah well it
was [ __ ] just a bit under
under a big thicket yeah basically
because i guess the house bushes just
took over at the trees and everything
and yeah and it was something from the
1800s and there hadn't been anybody in
it since the probably the 1950s
and uh once i saw it even though i had a
shotgun on me at the time
[ __ ] i looked at it looking in
through those [ __ ] windows look i was
looking into a blackness of a cave
i got you know chills went down my spine
and i'm like oh uh-uh
because it looked furnished yeah i mean
it was [ __ ] spooky
for all you know there's a dead old lady
from [ __ ] 50 years ago in there you
know
i don't think i could have resisted
going out of luck
maybe there's the dead you couldn't
fight all those [ __ ] bushes to
get to it yeah i mean i needed a machete
you need a machete you need a machete to
get to it
yeah but i could see it just a
dilapidated old two-story house yeah
like 1880s we'll see i
i wrote a story like several years
here's a weird thing there was no road
or street yeah probably there used to be
long gone yeah there used to be but
there was
no i wrote a story like that like
several years ago because
i was thinking about it because when we
had like i think this is back in 2004
like when we had it here in central
florida we had like four or five
hurricanes like in like a six week
period
and it like tore like my [ __ ]
backyard all up like it like a bunch of
trees fell down and [ __ ] like that
and i was thinking to myself one day i
was just like looking out the window and
i was like
man what if there was like a house
hidden back there in the woods that i
had never known was there that was like
there the whole time and like i had
never known about it so like i ended up
writing a story like kind of related to
that
so that's kind of like what it reminds
me of like every time you tell me that
about
finding that [ __ ] house in the woods
yeah it's weird like just in the [ __ ]
bushes
we got 67 watching us right now that's i
think that's a record
at one time yeah that's like pretty good
yeah
we gotta get back to the main story
though yeah so like like i said the
paris catacombs one they're still like
just like with most of these videos
there's a lot of controversy over
whether this is real [ __ ] or whether the
person that made the original
documentary that said they found the
footage whether
they actually made the footage and
whether it was fake um this actually did
turn up somebody mentioned it i think i
mentioned it earlier that it was on like
world scariest places or whatever like
on the travel channel or sci-fi channel
and i think it was on like [ __ ] ghost
adventures and [ __ ] like that too
but um you know so like i said i don't
know if it's real or not
but a lot of people um have said that
there's kind of like a lot of creepy
sounds in there and like at one point i
don't
know if you saw like in the video but
there was like this weird
like figure like drawing on the wall
kind of like somebody had been down
there and like drew this weird thing so
like people were talking about that
now this video right here i don't know
how well known this one is
um this is just one that i always really
that i always really liked that i always
found really creepy
now this one is just called i think it's
just called like floating girl or
levitating girl or something like that
in russia now let me like turn
let me turn this down so here's this guy
in russia and he's got his little dog
his dog's name is tarzan by the way and
uh
so tarzan starts barking and like runs
off because it's a masculine dog
because apparently the dog sees
something so he's like hey tarzan come
back here so he keeps like yelling for
the dog to come back but the dog doesn't
come back
so then if you look he goes down this
like little road right here and look
look look there's a girl like floating
oh yeah i've seen that yeah it's like
for some reason i really really like
this one
and the guy's like what the [ __ ] yeah
and then they're like and then they're
like oh no and then they run off like
they were doing something they weren't
supposed to be doing
well there's a strategic reason why they
did it i love that one i love that one
they don't want you to know what
happened to the girl because girls hang
in there all along
[Laughter]
she's on a wire well yeah i'm just
saying i really like the way that one
was done because it wasn't
there wasn't like a big build up there
wasn't like
um any kind of like oh [ __ ] there wasn't
like a jump scare there wasn't anything
like if you're gonna fake a video
do ones like that because that to me is
like way creepier
because you can put yourself in that
guy's shoes i'm just out in the woods
with my dog one day and then i just
turned the corner and there's a [ __ ]
girl floating in the air
and then like and then they just run off
it's like there's not a big monster
there's nothing like that
to me that's like way creepier and that
was one that i saw like probably
years ago i think it was first posted in
2016.
and uh that was just one that always
stuck with me because i just like liked
it so much
because you know it's i like that kind
of subtle that's a good shot it's a good
it's a good gag
yeah yeah that's what i'm saying all
right so um
actually i kind of have to go good so
are you going to like entertain
yeah you i'll entertain you
entertainment come back i'll get another
drink i'll make drinks for us when you
go
okay are there any commercials i have to
run
well i can run them in a minute because
we're only like an hour and a half
okay so let me see all right so i'm
now at the command module i'm at the
command module
i even got [ __ ] um evil spot with me
mirror spock i don't i don't necessarily
think he was evil
he was just uh the difference box see
what you guys are doing see what's
everybody
connor botslands there tom is still not
drinking of course i'm drinking man i've
been drinking since the beginning
of the show his wife's feeding him i
uh i made some mexican food today too i
took some of that
took some of that uh pork tenderloin
and i uh spiced that up slow cooked that
in a little bit of [ __ ] olive oil and
vegetable oil is nice man [ __ ] it
then i just uh pulled it pulled pork
i also got pork shoulder i'm gonna cook
up later see what i'm gonna do
they want janet wants me to croon too he
wants me to sing
yeah tom has a con
eating menudo you know i [ __ ] had
menudo one time in the army
my [ __ ] buddy mike chaffino miguel
miguel cioffino made some menudo we were
up in korea
and uh i don't remember how he made it
he had all the spices and everything got
the tripe and did it man that [ __ ] was
it had a good flavor the the the gravy
did
but when the tripe went in there it
wasn't my i didn't know i didn't like it
like i'm not a big internal organ kind
of guy
i could do without the all right there's
that rubber band i lost that earlier let
me get that right there and i'll make an
i'll make a all right he's gonna go make
some drinks
and i'm gonna start talking about
i'm the fastest peer ever well yeah it's
like you know i get [ __ ] done
i don't i don't uh you know dilly dally
i guess now i sound like a grandma yeah
so
uh what else is on my list here all
right so let's talk a little bit about
a little thing called the wyoming
incident
now this was supposedly
now i think most people know about a
real thing that happened the
max headroom incident or the max
headroom uh
broadcast or whatever they called it now
that happened back in 1987
in chicago now that was when
and this this actually kind of impresses
me because back in 1987
i imagine it was much harder to like
hack into
a tv broadcast than it would be like
nowadays
but someone actually managed to do it
and they
broke into this program with kind of
like a person wearing a max headroom
mask and if you don't know who max
headroom is
obviously you can google it it's like i
remember watching that show a lot when i
was growing up
and it just kind of had this person they
were like saying all these really weird
things and there was like this
um you know there was the guy in the
mask was like getting whipped by like a
woman in a
french maid outfit or some [ __ ] like
that so somebody had like interrupted a
broadcast and put that in there and to
this day as far as i'm aware
they um never did like find out who did
that or why they did it
so this other thing called the wyoming
incident i guess was kind of like
inspired by that so this was a similar
thing
where and i think i have video of this
as well this might not be the original
um filming today
but it's the same kind of thing where
there's like a news broadcast and then
there's like a break-in
oh no
oh thanks what is what is that that's
not fine or we got a pineapple
out of pineapple oh okay i'm not a
pineapple that's a lemon with a little
bit of cranberry
yeah that's special punch special
special punch that's what i call that
[ __ ]
it's good well let me let me try it's
good you're gonna like it
yeah good huh whoo it's tart there's
cranberry in there yeah yeah
okay i was gonna say yeah so
i was talking about heavy you've heard
of the max headroom incident right
oh the tv yeah that happened yeah that
happened back in 87 that's a really good
that's a really good story well and like
i said that's kind of a lot of people
know about that one and that was
actually real like somebody actually did
you know break into a tv broadcast with
that kind of stuff although nobody knows
why
they did it and they never caught the
person they know who it is though
well they're pretty sure well like i
said it seems like
i'm kind of impressed by that because
back in 87 it was probably much harder
like i said earlier to
bust into a tv broadcast i heard a story
of some guys that
at least a group of people that thought
they knew who it was yeah
we'll see what you say and then i can
chime well i wasn't necessarily talking
about that one i was talking about
another like a recent one
that was called the wyoming incident
that i think was like inspired by that
yeah this one actually started in
late january of 2007 now a bunch of
videos started circulating
um you know along with the ones that i'm
showing right now that say like you were
ill and like show all these spaces and
stuff
and they they started circulating around
the same time as like all these kind of
creepypasta stories
and these stories said that these were
from a um hijacked tv broadcast
that happened in niagara county
hopefully i'm pronouncing that right
in uh wyoming nebraska wyoming nebraska
weird yeah why would you name a city the
same as florida
right there is a switzerland
florida yeah isn't that weird it's like
it's uh because i was driving to my
mom's house and
when she used to live near jacksonville
and i was like switzerland
there's a city called switzerland in
florida i don't get it like france
germany
[Laughter]
where you from from france germany
they're like well wait which is yeah
yeah i don't know why you would name
something i don't know i don't get it
but yeah so wyoming nebraska
[Laughter]
so a lot of people thought that this was
a real like hijacked
and it did a lot of like um you know it
kind of made the rounds it's like a real
story just like the max headroom one
which was actually real as far as i'm
aware
um but as time went on
people found out that the uh wyoming
incident as they called it
was actually dreamed up by
these two guys who worked at the website
something awful
uh called senor bambos and the detector
so they were making this as a sort of
arg
like an alternate reality game and
interestingly i think that because uh
i think it was night mind or nexbo
there's those are two like really good
channels if you want to check those out
they talk a lot about
arg's creepy videos like on youtube and
like they kind of
do really like in-depth like analyses
like what's going on behind them and
[ __ ]
and i think it was an expo did a
like a two volume set on uh wyoming
incident
and he kind of talked about the original
uh
you know first videos and then like it
kind of went
once everybody kind of found out it was
an arg like
people were still playing it and like
trying to figure it out like you do with
an arg
but then it just kind of like went off
the rails
and i guess because i guess like the
people like the two dudes that created
it like i don't know if they had some
kind of falling out or one of them
wanted to go in the one direction and
one of them kind of hijacked it and took
it another direction so it didn't really
it didn't really make any sense like it
didn't really seem to have like a
coherent storyline so people were kind
of getting like annoyed because they
couldn't figure it out
and then so it kind of went um it went
dormant for a little while but then as
far as i know
i think that in 2017 or 2018
they started up again so i don't know if
it's like the same guy or if it's like
the same
or if they've like figured it out
somehow i'm not really sure but it's
like
this is one that comes up a lot because
people are like always trying to figure
out like what all those
because i mean that's kind of the nature
of an arg is that particularly ones that
were
created you know kind of in the early to
mid 2000s
um very big with like [ __ ] binary
code and
you're lost on the
how can you be lost well see that's
it's just kind of like zen it's like the
sound of man we've got
one hand correct everybody in the
comments in the comment section is
talking about chicharrones and crackling
hey you guys we have been watching have
you guys if you have netflix in the us
at least i don't know about other
countries
but there is a documentary series on
there called taco chronicles
i think we mentioned it before and it's
like it's really really good it's
fascinating because like i said
spanish with subtitles but it's really
good yeah well because yeah other than
when they're in la a couple times they
go to elliott
and then it's a whole history of the
tacos all these different concepts and
all different kind of tacos
to have reached zen with the making of
taco all kinds of things it's awesome
it's like i'm really interested like i'm
not just interested in food because i
love to eat obviously but it's like
i'm interested in like the cultural
history of food and like how it relates
to like people in that culture
and the cool thing about taco chronicles
is that they will talk to these people
that have had you know like some of
these people have had like a taco stand
in their families
for like five generations you know what
i mean it's like
yeah my great great grandma started this
[ __ ] taco stand and it's like they
all like worked in it like subsequently
and they're like not because i feel like
if that happened in the u.s people be
like man i'm not doing that i want to do
my own thing i'm my own person
but it's like they don't really do that
there that's like it's very like the
tradition
was very important to them and like
they're really really into
like remember that one that they did i
can't remember what kind of tacos it was
but
where they were making everything in
copper pots yeah and they were talking
about like they had this
so they then they had this yeah like
special they made them like one at a
time and
he like hammered them out by hand and
like all the stuff like most people
don't make them like that anymore
but he had been doing it for like three
or four generations like this
transsexual
transsexual basket tacos that's right
yeah yeah yeah
basket tacos she was awesome which is a
transsexual
ran around selling tacos out of a basket
that was a good story
yeah i liked it i liked the basket tacos
true yeah also mark's uh
saying that it's time to get me to sing
purple rain
let me make something clear i only do
[ __ ] there's only three reasons why i
do [ __ ] like sing or take clothes off or
any kind of dance and [ __ ]
one gotta be a super chat two
two i gotta be half loaded three if i
wanna do it sometimes i'll do it
for free you know but no you don't have
to be fully loaded yeah not right just
partially sometimes i'll do it just
cause you know but
no have you i don't think you've ever
taken your wait have you taken your
shirt off on this show yeah they paid me
that's right they paid me one time one
time because you said you said you would
they paid me twenty dollars to take my
shirt
[Laughter]
give me a couple more years man i've
only been working for a couple years
it'll be right but uh yeah i would love
to sing purple rain but i don't remember
all the lyrics
i don't either actually and now now it's
kind of bothering me all i'd be able to
do is go
purple
[Music]
[Laughter]
well because now that i'm thinking about
it i'm like well [ __ ] do i even know any
of the words
no i don't know anything you neither
always [ __ ] i like prince but i like to
listen to prince i wouldn't i wouldn't
try to sing like prince
yeah you know i know the words of a lot
of his songs but not a big dude i'm like
5'6 but prince was like five three i
think
he was like he was like my height yeah
he was little and
you gotta be trained up and you've gotta
have the right size
diaphragm and you know what i mean
to to sound like that you have to be
able to [ __ ]
do a little bit of falsetto and [ __ ]
with your voice too because he used to
he used to try to sing sexy see it was
like a
feminine he was he had that bisexual
voice
yeah it was like it was it was
transsexual
it was ma male and female simultaneously
but it came off as being manly though in
a weird way
well it's prince he could france he can
do that that [ __ ] broke all
kinds of rules see
just yes yeah he did you did i like
prince prince was [ __ ]
a great talent i still can't believe he
died drugs drugs are a hell of a drug
they are well you know i can't believe
it he was on some kind of a uh
uh what do you call it a kind of an
opioid
type drug yeah he's addicted to that
which is funny because dudes that get
addicted to that kind of [ __ ] they spend
most of their time sleeping they [ __ ]
age beautifully
well yeah that's what i mean look at all
the [ __ ] heroin addicts yeah stuff
like that man
as long as like i said either die when
you're 25 or you live forever
as long as they're eating as long as
they're eating right and have people
take care of them they're like a vampire
they just spend all the time to [ __ ]
sleeping and get up and [ __ ] put on a
performance and then they go back to
sleep yeah
like i said look at [ __ ] piggy pop
and [ __ ] like that yeah crap
he's he's remarkably welcome tyler the
cave like for how old they are they're
like
like really well presented with surprise
surprise wouldn't surprise me if [ __ ]
mick jagger is a junkie he's probably a
jockey
and he [ __ ] lasted a long time i mean
[ __ ] see that's like it's
20 years ago really tempting it's
tempting yeah
[Laughter]
they're not productive because they just
spend so much time sleeping i don't know
some of them seem pretty productive i
think other people are doing that work
[Laughter]
well and i think it depends on the
person too because it's just like
everything else drugs don't
affect everyone the same way uh you know
so
some people that i think that are
productive when they're
relatively sober might be even more
productive on certain types of drugs i
think when i was in the detroit boston
scene i had friends that fell to heroin
and
uh like what happened to rich and stuff
well i think that you'd have to be like
an exceptional
person you either be you become a
worthless piece of [ __ ] sleeping
sleeping your life away and just can't
manage your business that's one thing
or you do something like what rich did
get into an argument over the damn
volume of [ __ ] the television while
he was watching excalibur and blew his
brains out in front of his [ __ ]
girlfriend he was a good dude
ex-army guy and he was 50 something
years old and he looked like he's about
30
with all these little
20-something-year-old junky girlfriends
you know he's old goth
guy you know old school goth guy he was
good real cool dude he's a fashion model
after he got out of the army
you know local local to the boston scene
in the
punk rock and goth scene up around roth
rat you know in the rathskeller
this is the old boston i think probably
the worst thing about drugs
and like i said i'm not i'm not one of
those people that's just like don't do
drugs don't do drugs because it's like
you know people can kind of within
reason can do [ __ ] to their you know
to their own bodies like i said within
everything in moderation
yeah and it's like in moderation because
i feel like a lot of people do as long
as you don't like do it all the time and
it just like gets in the way of like you
having
a life i don't really have a problem
with it but i think
the worst thing about it is that it
exacerbates problems you might already
have like if you are already depressed
if you already have like
a mental issue or something like that it
might just make it worse i would never
say
i would never recommend heroin ever no i
wouldn't
most people to try i'm just kidding like
i'm just saying that like
no most people that try it never really
come back from it they like it
it's real good if you want to try heroin
and don't want to get
addicted just smoke opium it's a lot
milder and you can walk away from that
and it has like similar similar effects
yeah it's nicer that's why i smoke and
in certain countries like i smoked that
in the middle eastern place where it was
illegal you know like i don't really
break i tried not to break any laws that
i'm in the united states you know
uh but in dahab egypt which is like a
little [ __ ]
egyptian stoner town which is gone kind
of mainstream
recently but that was where you could
get stuff like hashish and
opium and you could yeah it's legal
there right so it's not like yeah
sort of illegal in that town it's
probably not legal in egypt
yeah you know what i'm talking about
yeah
in some of those countries you know what
i mean a [ __ ] law is very piecemeal
you can smoke it there it's a tourist
town well like i said it's kind of like
vegas and prostitution in the us
like pretty much everywhere prostitution
is illegal in the us
except for parts of actually parts of
vegas parts of reno yeah
dinner time i was in da hab it was just
a bunch of [ __ ] filthy ass [ __ ]
bedouin tents on the beach with these
[ __ ] little ratty looking
restaurants piping out jimi hendrix
music on the [ __ ] beach and sitting
there getting loaded
there was some irish [ __ ] street
urchin girl [ __ ]
sitting next to me we were just smoking
because she didn't have any money i
think she was a prostitute probably
but she had she had been in da hab for
about 10 years
her teeth some of her teeth are rotten
and she was wearing arabic clothing
so she just according to her she just
went there and stayed
well that's where all the drugs were all
the drugs were
so why leave yeah yeah she tried to put
it on me and i was like no no thanks
i didn't know where that [ __ ] would be
because you know what i mean i was
[ __ ]
you know being in the army you know you
just
you might [ __ ] get kind of thirsty
but you're just not that
desperate your discipline kicks in
you're like
ah no no no not not that street urchin
she was cute though but you could tell
she'd been living on this [ __ ]
on that beach for about six seven years
probably
yeah she was from ireland um yeah
and just decided to go down there she
just went to the hop and never left
that's fascinating wore out her clothes
and just started buying arabic clothes
i'm just so fascinated by people i do by
individual people's like stories like
that
yeah that have these like [ __ ] weird
stories yeah because i just
it especially people that do stuff that
i would never
like have thought of doing or like would
never see myself doing
any by any stretch i didn't ask but i
just got the feeling that she just kind
of
became a hooker basically if that's what
well i guess if you were in a country
where you know you didn't really speak
the language or you didn't really fit in
or whatever i mean
you would if you're a woman you
eventually end up doing that i think she
was just there for the [ __ ]
she was there for the opium yeah so you
know
beezna says no teeth to get in the way
wink wink she had teeth
she had teeth it's just that some of
them were kind of gray
you know what i mean i could tell she
hadn't brushed her teeth in a while
there wasn't any running water to speak
up and [ __ ] dihab from what i saw
yeah yeah i ran in a [ __ ] hotel and
it looked like a horse stall
yeah concrete and [ __ ] and when i got it
i rented it for like a dollar
all right and then [ __ ] when i saw on
the inside
i just said i [ __ ] that i slept
outside the sand it was the same [ __ ]
it was more comfortable just sleep on
the sand and that's free
that was free but you know it was only a
dollar
what you get what you pay for because
the [ __ ] the the beds were just
concrete slabs
with like a mat on them that was only
like a quarter of an inch thick like a
piece of foam
it's like something you'd put a horse
man even two people had better babies
yeah and after i came back from [ __ ]
from [ __ ] smoking that opium i was
like i looked at that and said man i
want to be in here
so i just slept on a [ __ ] beach i
don't blame you i woke up with a [ __ ]
old three-legged dog licking me in the
face
oh yeah cause they chopped one of the
dog's legs off
all the [ __ ] dogs arabs don't like
dogs they'll
kill a dog if it comes within arm's
reach and the dogs ran around in a
filthy pack trying to [ __ ] beg for
food you know
woke up the dogs [ __ ] licking me on
their face like that and woke up
and then the arab dudes are [ __ ]
running one started laughing
at me because the dog white dude's
sleeping out
[ __ ] sand with it like a dog licking
his face yeah he was the guy who owned
the hotel
or the horse stable basically
okay if it was good enough for jesus
it's good enough for you yes exactly
they were trying to get me sleeping
i said [ __ ] that i went in there and
just formed the sand up in a nice
position
had a like i said it's probably more
uncomfortable it's a lot more
comfortable than that [ __ ] slab
i mean it's just like weirdly enough i
don't know how i
i don't know how i like end up reading
these articles but i was reading this
article earlier today about
people uh giving their worst like
bathroom experiences like the grossest
place you've ever peed or whatever
and uh you know a lot of people said
[ __ ] like cbgb's and stuff like that
which you know
yeah i've been in punk clubs in pretty
[ __ ] disgusting bathrooms it's like
you have to be really really drunk to
use them but
some people were talking about being in
like india or thailand or something
and uh you know where the toilets you
know if
especially like if you're kind of out in
a rural area where the toilet is
basically just like a hole in the ground
and uh you just kind of have to squat
over it and some people are not aiming
so good
they're in there asking when she was
british she said no she was irish
yeah she was irish i remember that
clearly yeah
yeah pale pale skin
dark hair short she was cute
but yeah but it looked like something
out of star wars looked like something
from the sand people
[Laughter]
been out in that desert a long time
[ __ ] sleeping on that [ __ ]
beach in in like fake arabic clothing
that you buy
that they sell to the tourists you know
what i mean where they have the guys on
the [ __ ]
those those guys will set up the little
merchants will set little tables
anywhere try to sell you incense and
[ __ ]
sure sell you [ __ ] weird [ __ ] like
honey or something or
[ __ ] a fake perfume
they'll hand mix perfume yeah and sell
it out of a [ __ ]
hand blown glass bottle it was [ __ ]
really cool looking bottles yeah i've
seen those yeah they are
they are very nice and they'll sell you
a copy of
like any of your major [ __ ] um
uh like you know like like say you want
obsession
yeah they have a copy of that yeah for
like a couple of dollars
but it would the the smell would last
like a long time it was almost better
i don't they knew how to make it they
didn't mix it well like i said if one
person can make it it's all just
chemistry like for a while several years
back i got really interest
interested in like perfume mixing yeah
and like read a bunch of books about how
to do it and stuff well they'd also sell
clothes they sell
tourist clothes to the [ __ ] tourists
you know what i mean it'd be like
egyptian men's clothing or women's
clothing or whatever you know
white white egyptian dudes wore this
white [ __ ] shirt they went all the
way down to their ankles to me i'm gonna
tell you it's a shirt
yeah i've seen yeah i know what you're
talking about i've seen those we'd [ __ ]
with them and call it a dress though too
you know what i mean because we'd see
them you know we're in their country but
we'd still [ __ ] with them
it's like call it a dress like your
skirt you know that kind of [ __ ] you
know
well i bet it's more comfortable than
having like pants going up yeah crawling
up your butt sometimes they have pants
underneath them anyway yeah and uh well
they had some women's stuff that was
kind of like that
that was uh look like something [ __ ]
mary from the bible would wear or
something you know
yeah yeah and put a shawl on and that's
what she had on
but she was irish yeah okay and it was
just stuff that people
bought her for and you could get that
[ __ ] for like three or four dollars
you know yeah she didn't have anything
she just had that
yeah that's weird she just wore it all
the time and she just walked around
and i guess when it got dirty she just
[ __ ] bought another one asked
somebody to buy her another one because
tourists were constantly in there
yeah you know and i was eating and she
just sat down she's what you eating
food i don't yeah it was like hummus and
[ __ ]
because i have one it says yeah all this
shit's cheap so
why not yeah you get like hummus for
like
a dollar well she's probably she's been
living lately she's been living like
this
i just got her whatever she wanted and
[ __ ] she's asking me questions and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] then i
she says you want to hook i says yeah
let's get a hook and it's [ __ ] this
and we started smoking opium
yeah yeah i hope you but there wasn't
enough opium to like make you want to
hit that
oh no oh no i don't know what happens
is you just start slowing down and you
get more and more and relaxed and
everything starts moving faster and
faster around you and you don't care
and it's like smoking liquid grapes it's
like this grape flavored
it's a great [ __ ] uh tobacco it
tastes like a real heavy grape
flavor oh i like that yeah it's real
smooth you don't cough or anything you
can
even if you're a non-smoker you can't
cough it it's just
goes right in now i want some you start
moving in slow motion you get real
relaxed it's just like going under
sedation
yeah you know and like time becomes
meaningless
you could sit there for like three or
four hours and it just didn't mean
anything you know
it's just like those old movies about
opium dens yeah you go in there and
there's
people laying around going yeah yeah
the good thing about it though is that
when you snap out of it you're not like
oh i need more of that
you don't have that sensation you're
like whew you're like you're satisfied
you're like oh that was nice
yeah and then you just keep going you
know what i mean well yeah that [ __ ]
when it wears off you
instantly want more well you said that
um
cocaine cocaine will instantly do that
you'll instantly want more
it's very dangerous yeah you have to
have a good will
power but not a lot of but you know not
all drugs are like that like some are
more like oh i need some more right away
or some are kind of like oh every now
and then it's like a nice treat you know
from from what my friends have told me
though heroin if you take heroin
when you come off of that you instantly
want more it does seem like
people that i've known that did heroin
it really did seem like most of them
were kind of like
they were always you'll become a junkie
yeah you were always
looking for the next one i wouldn't [ __ ]
with it because it was so addictive
most of the dudes that i knew that were
into that [ __ ] didn't live long
uh they were cool when they started but
they were [ __ ] bags by the time they
died people didn't like them
and a lot of it had to do with the fact
that it was the girls that came along
with it yeah as soon as you when you get
all the hangers on yeah like hey you've
got drugs
as soon as you get involved that heroin
all of a sudden you get real good
looking
all these [ __ ] women that are into
this [ __ ] [ __ ] appear and then you
know and as long as you have that heroin
they're around you
you know and that
that's kind of a seductive lifestyle i
guess
i guess so for some guys first yeah for
some people
me i was indifferent to that i was
popular with women without that i didn't
need
i was never soup i was never really into
drugs i was never really into drinking
until i got older but i know yeah
because i knew some people that were
into it but it's like
it was just never really something i
wasn't like super judgy about it it's
just like nothing that really appealed
to me
there are people that we know from the
scene that if i was involved in drugs
they'd be fogging up on me
because it's not real obvious when
you're talking to them you know what i
mean yeah of who it is i'm gonna say on
the show
well yeah you better know what we're
gonna get in trouble yeah on the show
there's some of them well
you know if i [ __ ] was into meth or a
crystal or some [ __ ] like that then that
one and that one and that one or [ __ ]
this one's into the
they have they give you little codes
yeah yeah they ask you about it
well yeah they're trying to like fight
yeah trying to see if you have it yeah
who's got the [ __ ] yeah
it's like yeah man that has it all of a
sudden you're [ __ ] you go from
you go from a seven to an 11. oh
okay yeah he's got trouble he's got that
yeah he's got the drugs
in the comments no yeah they know i mean
like i said it's
you know i like every now and then
tom is talking just got in and thomas
talking about drugs
nice yeah yeah they just went on a drug
sidetrack it's like i'm not like i said
i'm not
super into like drunk but you know i've
done a few but it's like it's never
really anything that i'd want to do all
the time
you know what i'm saying yeah i don't
even really like weed all that much that
just that that made me feel
paranoid and like my life was flashing
by and like i didn't
everybody was like looking at me and i'm
like yeah i feel like that without weed
i don't really
yeah that exacerbated thanks michael
schafer says who wants to do the work to
hit something when you're on open yeah
you don't want to do the work
you're indifferent that's what i mean i
feel like that's kind of a more thing of
like just a chill
like an ultimate chill yeah which i like
the sound of that
more than ultimate chill it doesn't
immediately start calling you back
yeah yeah see that's that's what appeals
to me that kind of thing
i need things that like are relaxing
yeah i don't need stuff that induces
anxiety i don't need [ __ ] that makes me
like go faster or like think about more
so i don't need that i already have that
you'd like that one problem is is that
it used to be legal in the united states
and then when it
happened is you had opium dens
everywhere because given the choice
there's certain kinds of people that
would just sit there and smoke that [ __ ]
all [ __ ] day
yeah and then it's just fabric society
starts breaking down
yeah because everybody's just laying
around yeah feeling good yeah you got 30
of the people just laying around [ __ ]
telling the other people to feed them
and [ __ ]
yeah yeah so i can understand why it's
illegal
i mean michael says food tastes better
on weed but see i don't really need that
problem either because then i would just
like eve get even fatter because i would
just be like eating more all the time
because it's already it's like i want to
eat everything because everything's
delicious
i never liked weed that's what i mean
i've done it a few times and it's just
like i can't
yeah i'm not like i said it probably
affects other people in other ways
because i've heard like a lot you know
different people telling me different
things but i don't to me it just made me
more anxious and more
and paranoid and i didn't like it like
and it and it made like everything like
go by really fast
like i felt like i was missing a bunch
of stuff i'm like hey that
you know that was just i was just doing
that and then like already it's like 10
minutes later and like i didn't know
where that 10 minutes went and i didn't
like that
because i felt like i was like losing
track of time and i was losing track of
what was going on
and i didn't really like that feeling so
all right let me get back to this
yeah get back to this man all right so
let me i'm not saying americans are
always used to always are scared of
getting sued but in mexico you just kick
your ass
that's starting to develop here too now
in the past couple months people just
kicking each other's asses or setting
their houses on fire
go ahead yeah biesner says weed gives me
a panic attack
i kind of had the same not quite a panic
attack but it really it was not pleasant
it was like not a pleasant experience
like everybody's watching you yeah i
just felt like everyone was looking at
me and it's like i just
like [ __ ] was going by really fast i'm
like what happened this what
what am i doing that's like you know
what i mean i don't like it if you take
lsd
they're watching you and then you put on
a performance i didn't feel like i was
ways coming out of them
i didn't feel like i was being watched
on ellis i i actually really liked lsd
because
i didn't feel like people were watching
me but i did feel like
i and i think i remember telling you
this too i said i know
now because i used to like make fun of
hippies and stuff like
not me not in the main way but like
thank you cool kitty thank you thank you
cool kitty
i but you know just hippies is like oh
we're all one with the universe blah
blah blah
but like when i did lsd i'm like oh i
get what they're talking about now
i got it yeah one of the universe and
all that because that's exactly what you
feel like
you feel like and you feel like
everything is okay and like everything's
gonna be all right i gotta set the stage
for that one
yeah i wanna go to mexico and go do that
ayahuasca
i would i wouldn't mind doing that but i
don't like all the feeling of like being
feeling sick and vomiting
i don't have a [ __ ] about see i don't
like feeling like vomiting i don't like
diarrhea and vomit i don't care i want
to go talk to some alien souls
talk to alien souls alien alien
robotic souls and weird [ __ ] that
they're talking about michael says we're
all looking at you jenny i know yeah
i try to pretend like you're not yeah
i don't mind that's all right but yeah
so speaking of
people looking at people i wanted to
talk about
this [ __ ] i don't know if you guys
know about this dude's channel
so this dude has a youtube channel his
name is benjamin bennett
and he started uploading videos i think
he started in 2013
and all of his videos and he's posted
like
a [ __ ] ton of them i can't remember how
many there it's like at least a hundred
maybe more
all of his videos are like at least four
hours long
and every single one of them is him
sitting
cross-legged on his apartment floor
staring at the camera
and smiling and not moving for four
hours
and he's just like sitting there doing
that i heard about this guy so yeah so
it's this whole thing i think i have a
picture of him he's like super creepy
looking do i have a picture of him
somewhere
yeah right there so he just sits there
and does that
for four hours every single
day and he posts a video every single
he needs to repaint his room man
i know it looks like a i'm expecting a
rat to run by
well the funny thing about it is like
okay so
he's been asked like because he goes
it's his real name and everything like
that so people have asked him this is
his
sitting and stare it's sitting in
smiling series
so he did get asked like what the [ __ ]
like why are you doing that like
are you a crazy person and he basically
said well
when i first got on youtube in 2013 i
noticed that no one had a channel like
this
yeah which so he's just gonna i wonder
why that so i'm just gonna fill that
niche right i guess
and um also i guess that he was it was
some kind of like weird
like art project like an endurance test
kind of like if he could actually just
sit there and like not move
like he blinks and [ __ ] but it's like he
just sits there and smiles at the camera
for four hours and doesn't move
and he um so he said that it's like all
he does
is um he just drinks some water before
he starts filming and then he goes to
the bathroom and then he just sits there
and does it
except in one of the videos i can't
remember what number it was
but one of the videos i guess he'd
forgotten to go to the bathroom
beforehand so he actually does pee
himself you can see like the pee coming
out from underneath him
so yeah and my favorite and i think this
was somewhere around like
sitting and smiling number 51 or 52 i
can't remember exactly
but it was the one where somewhat
somebody
broke into his apartment while he was
sitting there
and he totally does not react
damn he just sits there staring at the
camera smiling
you can see the door like the rattle and
then it opens behind him
and apparently the person that broke in
like kind of came in and like looked and
saw what was going on was like nope
and just got the [ __ ] out it was so
[ __ ] funny
because he didn't move he didn't look he
didn't jump he didn't
he wasn't startled or nothing he just
sat there
and stared and it's like super creepy so
i went to his channel
like a couple days ago and i don't know
if he does that series anymore like he
did however many hundred videos there
were but
they're all called that sitting and
smiling number one sitting at smiling
number two or whatever
and he did like a whole bunch of series
of those and then now he has a new
series
which i think is called walking and
talking or
something like that and i think it's
like him just like i'm not sure what it
is but it's like him walking around in
the woods
like saying something rather i didn't
really watch any of them but so i don't
think he does the sitting and smiling
series anymore
but he did like 200
something of those something like that
maybe even almost 300
of him just sitting there every single
day for four hours
staring and smiling at the camera can
you [ __ ] imagine
yeah and then just like peeing on the
floor and then somebody breaking into
the apartment him like
he didn't even flinch
he didn't even flinch like when somebody
came in he was just sitting there
yeah i'm not into it it was like really
disturbing
it was really disturbing i'm not feeling
it i'm just saying that like creeped me
out that creeped me out more than like
the ghost videos and [ __ ] like that
because that's
commitment well that's just his that's a
commitment
that's his fault he's peeing in his
pants and [ __ ] he should have [ __ ]
took a leak before he did the show
if you ask me he's probably doing it on
purpose just to get more
more hits that's probably a part of this
show
well they're trying to bet the break-in
was staged it might have been
and like because he really did i don't
see how like anyone who wasn't
medicated yeah could just like not go to
my house i'd jump up start fighting and
get you out of here
that's what i mean i'm like if i'm here
by myself which i'm not usually because
you're usually here but if i'm here by
myself
and i hear like the dryer the dishwasher
makes a funny noise i'm like jumping up
going like who the [ __ ] is that and
stabbing your head
yeah but i gave you guns well yeah he
does yeah the gun's in here so you know
[Laughter]
but we lo i mean we live in a safe
neighborhood we're not really all that
worried about it but we're keeping it
safe
i don't know if we're keeping it safe
it's just kind of like okay i'm keeping
it safe
no i'm just saying that it was kind of
like safe before we get it but yeah it's
like
so i don't know this really like
the thing about youtube and especially i
guess like the longer it goes on
and the more people are trying to get
noticed like especially if you like come
up with an energy because [ __ ] man it's
like
i really like the idea of args and i've
you know toyed around with the idea of
doing one myself but it's like there are
so many
that you really need to do something
different
to you know have to have it stand out
from everything else so it's like
i mean i admire his like shtick because
nobody else thought of doing that i mean
it's like i said it's a big commitment
to your art just to sit there for four
hours a day and like not move and just
like stare at i wouldn't want to do that
but he got like kind of known for doing
it i don't know if he went on to do
other things and like you know was kind
of
but his name is kind of known and we're
talking about him so i guess that means
something right
yeah they're asking me about the 1911. i
haven't had a 1911 since the night
since the 90s i had an old springfield
one
now i'm on to like bigger and better
things i like
[ __ ] walthers smith and wesson
i like the [ __ ] smith and wesson ez
that that's [ __ ]
it's like a 1911 real slim line nine
real
easy direct slide back pretty neat i
like most of the walther series
p99 uh
see what else um
yeah that's all i'm going to talk about
a bunch of ar-15s aks
i got i got some [ __ ] neat [ __ ]
you'd love it neat [ __ ] yeah most of it
all stuff i built
next i'm going to build is i'm going to
build a what would stoner do 2020.
it's what would eugene stoner do eugene
stoner
used plastic lower they're working on
that look at
plastic lower faxing upper the [ __ ]
facts and slim line [ __ ] barrel with
the integral [ __ ] super
flash suppressors on it 16 inches
[ __ ] upper with [ __ ] no forward
assist
um carbon fiber handguards free-floating
barrel
that self-contained buffer one with the
[ __ ]
one with the [ __ ] self-contained
piston uh
probably facts and [ __ ] chrome chrome
bulk carrier group and bolt
mid length gas system flat top
probably something like a sig red dot
you know the deal no i'm trying to get
like a four pound rifle
that's what i'm looking for it's gonna
be [ __ ] badass
with the [ __ ] um tlr-1
[ __ ] match trigger drop in
so that's that's that that's what's
coming now go ahead jim
pepper says jenny please make an arg i
do actually do want to because i'm
really into like multimedia because you
know i like i really like designing
board games and [ __ ] like that and i
like the idea
of doing something multimedia that
appears to be real or appears to be
you know that kind of thing so i have
been like looking at i have like a
bunch of other projects i got to finish
first including our cookbook
but after that that's my next big
project that i want to get into i really
want to do something like that because i
just
i love that idea but like i said there's
so many out there trying to get noticed
that you really have to i really i
really want to make it good so i really
want to like think of like an
angle that no one's really done before
or
that hasn't been done all that much so
people will notice it i don't know
so the next thing i want to talk about
is i guess she technically wasn't
discovered on youtube but i think her
shit's kind of on there now
is uh chip chan now do you guys
don't know who chip chan is she is this
korean woman
uh no one's entirely sure how old she is
now her videos
first started going up it was like a
webcam
[Music]
uh and it first started uh going up in
2008 i think it was
um and i think it originally initia it
was on
4chan i think and somebody like
discovered it on there now this is a
woman
no one knows quite how old she is but
she's basically just in her apartment
and the webcam is like filming her
like pretty much all the time because a
lot of the time she's just sleeping and
stuff
but apparently she thinks that she has
been
implanted with a mind control weapon
and she thinks that she's being held
hostage by
a corrupt police officer who she just
calls p
and that when she sleeps or when the
camera is not on him or whatever like he
comes in
and like [ __ ] with her and stuff and so
she'll like be in her apartment
like i said most of the videos are just
her sleeping but when she's awake she'll
put up like all these signs
you know what i mean like around her
apartment so you can read them and like
i said i can't
i can't read korean so i don't know like
what they say but they they're all kind
of like this
where it's like she'll put all these
signs up that say all these kind of like
weird warning things
and so she first started like streaming
or like her webcam like went
up in on 4chan in 2008
and so then people started like watching
it because i think when the
webcam first started like she was
sleeping through most of it and like
when people would watch it
they just saw this woman and they
thought maybe she was dead
so they s you know because she sleeps a
lot
so they kind of started like looking
into like investigating
now somebody from 4chan i believe like i
found her
uh she had a blog like on wordpress
and apparently she had like a whole
bunch of other ones and that's where she
was telling the whole story about the
mind implanting
and um apparently it's like she says
that the
mind implanting thing is like in her
ankle i guess it was like implanted in
her ankle
and there that there's also a chip like
under her left eyebrow
that she thinks that somebody put there
she's tripping
i think she might have schizophrenia
because that's like a pretty common
uh thing that schizophrenics uh say that
they think that someone is controlling
implants and they have like implants
like from the government or from aliens
or something like that or somebody's
watching them or telling them what to do
so it's weird because she has all these
webcams and it's not just one it's like
a whole bunch of them like they're all
over her apartment
and all of her rooms have all these like
signs that are written in korean like i
said
and she tells the people like on her
videos
um about p this policeman who supposedly
comes in there although as far as i know
no one's ever seen anybody coming in or
out of the apartment other than her
and but she says he comes in there and
like does things
so like i said she'll sleep for like 12
hours at a time
and she just gets like these [ __ ]
rashes and she gets like this [ __ ]
and she'll take pictures of like weird
wounds on her skin and all this other
kind of stuff like it's implants and all
this [ __ ]
and she's been doing this for like
[ __ ] years and years and years
now i think that over the years like
that these
um web streams have been going i think
she has left the apartment a few times
so it's not like she's just in there all
the time
um and she has moved like
you know she has moved to like different
apartments but then she sets up webcams
in the new apartment
and then just starts like doing this
over again and
so people will like chat with her on her
live streams but she doesn't answer but
if you email her sure
she apparently will answer so like i
said
as far as i know this is still going on
she's still been going on
you know like all this time since 2008
and i don't know don't people are trying
to like figure out if she has somebody
to take care of her because
she clearly has some mental issues um
but
like i said even though the webcam seems
to be going all the time no one really
sees anybody come in there like so i
don't really know
if anyone's taking care of her if she's
getting any kind of like mental health
care or anything like that because she
definitely does seem like she has some
problems
but like a lot of people got like really
interested in this girl because
um because it was just like this [ __ ]
weird webcam of like this girl just like
sleeping all the time and then just like
sitting in there like talking about the
[ __ ]
yeah it's like super weird so what was
that
they're trying to get me sidetracked on
guns this isn't a gun channel i'm not
going to
ask you you can if you want it's like
like i said this is going on i'm not
going to tommy guns
tommy guns are too heavy they're too old
uh
it's not a modern firearm just the way
the magazines work where the drums work
very heavy uh [ __ ] it's just not
modern
and uh no the the [ __ ]
the class three class three is only 200
bucks doesn't cost as much as you think
it does
they're easy to get that now you just
have to know how to do the paperwork
um there's just so many there's just so
much good [ __ ] out there in terms of
submachine guns
nine millimeters the way to go 45 is
just not really the way to go anymore
not so much because of the round but
just because of the [ __ ] firearms
that go with it
[ __ ] 100 200 rounds of 45 weighs a
lot more than 200 rounds and 9
millimeters you know it's just not
really a modern load uh
40 and hot loads of 40s better than 9
and 45. 45 is blowing out of proportion
of what it really is that's not really
good at armor defeating
you know anti-armor it's got a lot of
downsides to 45
and the tommy guns the last thing you
want
nowadays they got some [ __ ] really
great
three pound [ __ ] nine millimeter sub
machine guns that are just [ __ ]
awesome
it's just very obsolete those old things
okay great
you see them in the movies they look
cool in the movies you know this old
gangster gun
if you pick that thing up it is heavy as
[ __ ]
and um slow to reload uh very
uncontrollable
the controllability is not that good uh
it's just a very archaic way of doing it
okay good all right actually do you want
to do a commercial break now because
we're at
a good idea 20 minutes i've actually
used the restroom okay so i'll just do a
couple of commercials well one
commercial in a pookie video
okay and then we'll be back in a few
minutes where's my damn commercial at
here i go there it is all right hold on
we'll be back in just a couple of
minutes
you love true crime i love true crime
and i've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century
it's called the faceless villain and
volume 3 is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
caddy murders the carrie babies case
the frog boys the alcasar murders and
the anoka shira park dismemberment
incident
the faceless villain vol 3 is an
involving exploration of unsolved slangs
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or ebook
formats on amazon
or download the audiobook version from
audible.com and get ready for a chilling
journey through modern crime history
look at this look at this pookie
pookie hey chew that
hey hey hey
do this instead chew that chew that chew
that
there you go chew that see
it's super fun it's super fun
yeah nope
poke please stop please stop chewing
that please stop chewing that
please stop checking that
well what do you expect
she's sitting on the keyboard and it's
making a horrible noise
please stop
okay
look at what's she doing to my photoshop
yeah you didn't give a single [ __ ] do
you
what would you give in your mouth then
it's silly
when you do stuff in your mouth you're
chewing on so you're not going to be
chewing on
hey how about this like you wanted soft
thing also i have a chicken stick
i think this is a chicken dick you want
that
you want that
usually to knock it off the [ __ ] end
of the thing and stare at it aren't you
i know how you operate yep there it goes
where'd your little soft chewy go
where's your little soft chewy
oh man
yep you're such a troublemaker
you're such a troublemaker yeah
i know she's like mommy help me out
well you're the one that dropped it
you're the one that dropped it yeah
you're like a little goat you just want
to eat everything
just wants to eat everything
yeah you're chewing it get it in your
little bit and
get in your little mitten yeah
it's fun right fun
you done with that you done with that
you want more
no you just want to rub on it okay
that's fair enough
yeah you chew it you're gonna chew it
yeah oh that's okay mommy's got it
just don't bite my fingers
don't bite my fingers what'd you do with
your little soft one
huh what yeah that's okay i was just
mommy's tummy
she's getting hungry because it's lunch
time
yeah you're rubbing on it
you rub it on she's like giving give me
that back
oh okay
here yeah
which one you want the hard one your
cell phone
you can have both of them yes
you can both of them pick them up with
your little hand
now you lost interest okay
where are you going look i'm gonna thumb
your butt
gonna film your butt there it is
no and now she's doing that
don't make me spray you with lemon juice
pookie yeah
oh you heard that
hey hey
mommy's gonna get the febreze out i
don't really spray her with febreze
she's just scared of the bottle
okay bye
yeah where you going
okay
what's bach think of that
i was just laughing at that pokey video
i took that earlier i didn't realize i'd
like
that it was that long she is like um
i have a bottle of febreze in here that
i i don't spray her with it because that
would be mean
but she knows that it makes a hissing
noise because she's heard me spray it
like other places
so all i have to do is bring the bottle
out and go uh oh and she's like oh [ __ ]
and then she runs away so that's how i
get her to like stop chewing on things
because i just show her the
febreze bottle chloe says hey everyone
first time i've made it to a live cast
hey
welcome we're already pretty uh you know
who said that hammered at this point
chloe are do you see it yeah yeah how
you doing clay
that table is now definitely pookies
everything is pookies
she's just yeah she's [ __ ] pookie
pants will you [ __ ] stop it
i had to call her pookie pants i had to
pull
[Laughter]
leave spock alone
she knows what no means she doesn't
understand why he's standing there
he doesn't move
[Laughter]
don't bite me she's like plus it makes a
cool sound when i do it with my claws
because she really really digs like
scraping on things like on paper and
stuff with her claws she's like oh what
a cool noise that makes
yeah yeah
all right so you're all right mm-hmm
okay yeah
calling attention to me bourbon
well i'm just making sure because that's
the kind of thing like when we're out
clubbing and we've drank a lot and he
starts doing this like his soul's gonna
escape from his body
that's how you know when he's like
that's what i'm starting to actually
project i started yeah
so he's like trying to keep his soul
back in there getting it back in keeping
her flying around
[Laughter]
you'll be all right you'll make it yeah
i'm doing good all right i
i turned that down i turned that [ __ ]
that pulled pork on to low
on the like oh okay i'm gonna eat that
back up and slow cook that so when we
get off the show
make us like a little burrito or
something oh my god
what are you doing stop beating up spock
come here come here how you doing she's
being bad
leave things alone she's like no you
know i'm not gonna do that yeah it's the
same
in that video doing that same [ __ ]
walking around biting things and trying
to push things over
sitting on mommy's computer trying to
claw things and grabbing the tops of
books and pulling the books out of the
shelf
yeah she's [ __ ] like a little monkey
[Laughter]
leave it alone well she's always trying
to get attention that's yeah
she knows i'm gonna stop her that's why
she does it yeah she's like
she's not dumb yeah all right so next
video let's talk about
uh the so-called plague doctor video
also known as 11bx1371 so let me
find that cue that one up
so here's this little video right i'm
gonna turn this down because it's kind
of loud and i don't think there's any
sound that's worth
seeing so this is one that kind of uh
made the rounds now this was initially
not posted to youtube this was um
initially sent to
a swedish tech blog uh in 2015
and that website subsequently like uh
put it up on youtube or made it public
or whatever
now the weird thing about this video
like not only is that like the creepy
image of the plague doctor and
everything but also
i guess they're um a whole bunch of like
ciphers and different like codes and
[ __ ]
embedded in this video and if you
figure them out like a lot of people on
reddit are like super into like figuring
out all these
like weird coded videos and [ __ ] that
people post
um they kind of go to like really
disturbing imagery like
mutilated bodies and all this other kind
of [ __ ]
now apparently some of the imagery in
this
video that's encrypted in this video
goes to
stop it pokey no what are you doing
tearing all your [ __ ] out yeah tearing
out all your your hair stuff
oh yeah she does that she's like hey
because my hair brush pokey pants you
come here
kooky pants you come here stop it yeah
yeah she's going like [ __ ] you dad and
her [ __ ] tail's wagging like this
crazy okay because you're talking to her
she yeah she she does this so i react
yeah she'll go up and beat on the damn
window shades in the
[ __ ] in the morning and looking at me
you gonna come stop me
i can't man she's [ __ ] hilarious oh
look
they keep asking me questions i'm gonna
answer okay
they asked about the p90 now [ __ ] the
p90 all right
best sub gun going right now depending
on what kind of lower if you're using
full auto or semi-auto trigger package
best thing going right now if it's set
up right a cmmg
banshee you can look at that the banshee
which is an ar-15
style rotary delayed blowback
upper that's complicated but that's the
best thing going just because of the
modularity
yeah that's all i'm gonna say okay no
more guns stop asking
i wasn't sure if you were done stop
asking me about [ __ ] guns
too drunk for guns oracle says pookie
has tom well trained she doesn't
yes she does she is very smart she knows
exactly how to like manipulate
yeah she she decided like for a while
she likes to she likes to go out on the
back porch like out on the
from the sliding glass door but now she
decided she likes to go on the front
porch
so what she'll do though is she'll go to
like the sliding glass door in our
bedroom
and we'll kind of scrape on it and then
turn around and go
and then you go up to let her out and
she's like nope and then she runs but
then she runs to the front door
so she's like telling you that she wants
to go out the other door she's like i
want to go outside
but not here i want to go over there so
she's like really good at
communicating you know what i mean so
yeah so
like i said this plague doctor video
which is over now um
the the encryption and it like led to
all these like really weird like
mutilated victims also kind of had some
link to the boston strangler
investigation
um also some people have said that maybe
it's uh
like a bioterrorism threat like maybe
encoded
um although some people have said maybe
it's just a prank or maybe somebody's
just making it as an arg like i said
like to be mysterious or creepy or
whatever
um and then somebody like this guy named
parker wright
came forward and said that he was the
one that created the video
um but nobody knows if that's true or
not so
like i said this is kind of another one
where you're not really sure like where
the [ __ ]
uh genesis of these videos are so the
next one i want to talk about
we i think i talked about this one a
little bit on one of our creepy
disappearances
shows because this video right here
which is usually just listed as
um one one two dirt bag
um is just i mean the video itself is
not necessarily creepy because if you
look
it's just kind of like an old dude
laughing but the creepy thing about this
video
is the back story eight years
after uh maura murray disappeared
in 2004 and we talked about her on one
of our creepy disappearances shows
this video came online
now the name of this video was happy
anniversary and the username
was mister one one two dirk bag
now okay so in february of 2004
they found maura murray's wrecked car
on uh route 112 in new hampshire
and she has never been found
now when the video came up interestingly
because the video was called
you know one one two dirt bag her car
was found on one one two and her dad
had gone in the you know on the news and
called the person that took her a dirt
bag
so some people were speculating that
this was the dude that took her
because he called the video happy
anniversary and he
posted it like on an anniversary like of
her disappearance
so police were very interested and they
started like looking into
um who this dude was and [ __ ] like that
and i think he posted a couple of other
videos like one of them
he was like he was doing something
really monday like ironing or something
like that and then he was like singing
along it was like super super creepy
because he's just like this creepy old
dude
and i guess like the cops eventually
like figured out who he was
but i don't know if he had anything to
do with the disappearance or they didn't
have enough evidence
but the fact that he posted it and it
was just a video of him laughing
and it was called happy anniversary like
on the anniversary of her be of her
disappearing
and it was like right around the same
area so it's like
so a lot of people like kind of thought
it was related but i don't think they
were
ever able to like uh find any evidence
that
that it was related to her disappearance
or not and they've still never found her
like you know what i mean so i think
like i mentioned it on the
more when we talked about maura murray
like on one of our i can't remember what
disappearance this show was like the
first one or the second one i can't
remember because we've done like three
at this point
now another thing now you you gave me
this idea
this isn't exactly a youtube video but
it's kind of like
adjacent so because you told me about
the case that you heard on that uh
that wang chan yeah wang did a real good
job about it w-h-a-n-g
yeah exclamation point that's the name
of the channel which i don't know if
he's chinese or
american or korean-american but he's
cool as [ __ ] a little bit dude long
[ __ ] like
long hair and all like it looks like
something damn star trek
looks like something looks like
something out of a [ __ ] film about
mongolian warriors
and he does a really good show and i i
actually recommend wang
to subscribe to him he comes up with
some weird things like
oh [ __ ] like mystery songs
songs from the 80s and nobody knows who
made them and they're still trying to
figure out who made that song
or uh videos about girls from
back in the 90s who were farting on
cakes
and that [ __ ] went viral we were talking
all about yeah
yeah we were on the birthday show yeah
just weird [ __ ]
from the past that's weird weird
mysteries
so i like yang well he has a whole he
has a whole series called tales from the
internet which is where
which is where this video came from yeah
and i saw this on wang
and it's about mississippi and i was
really interested in this one so i
recommend it to jason jennings we need
to talk about that [ __ ] case that
supposedly took
place in mississippi because it was
creepy
turns out it was not real but it was
[ __ ] creepy well what ended up
happening
was that hold on one second before we go
these [ __ ] in the goddamn
the spas 12 is obsolete it was cool back
in the 80s all right but [ __ ] ak
shotguns [ __ ] beat it they got all
kinds of new semi-auto
magazine magazine fed shotguns that are
faster to reload that are [ __ ]
more modularity better optics you guys
are bringing up these old terminator
[ __ ]
terminator one shot guns and terminator
one [ __ ] you know what i mean that was
the 80s bro
[ __ ] the spas there's new [ __ ] there's
new [ __ ] out
you got to change with the time read
right now everyone says
yeah you need to [ __ ] listen to
musashi okay musashi tells you to stay
on top of weapons craft
new [ __ ] comes out figure out if it's
good or not throw away the old stuff
there's a lot of good [ __ ] a lot of good
shits come out new
new [ __ ] that i wish we had back in
service yeah
yeah it's real good uh
80s guns were guns of their time all
right
so they're in a lot of action movies
but they don't translate to the modern
world anymore okay now let's go back now
let's get off that subject you [ __ ] is
stuck
oh i forgot to mention i forgot to
mention we were talking about the uh
112 dirtbag case about the maura murray
in the videos he also refers to
um he also makes references to two more
disappearances which was uh
molly bish who was 16 now her body was
found so she was murdered
and also a 10 year old named patrick
mccarthy um
and they were all in like massachusetts
so like i said they were trying to find
this guy like
in relation to those but yeah so you
mentioned to me like we were in the car
coming back from the grocery store or
whatever
and you said you know wang did this
thing about this case in mississippi
which
turned out to be like it was about this
girl that got kidnapped and murdered
except it turned out it wasn't real
so i was kind of looking into it i
couldn't really find it and like wang
has like 50 bajillion videos so he
finally found it and sent it to me
now what what you didn't tell me which
would have actually helped a lot if you
had told me this little detail but that
it had to do with
the band slipknot not like that they
killed anybody but it was just like a
reference to them
so basically slipknot on one of their
albums
they had a song and i think there were
two songs on there initially
but the one that i'm thinking of i think
it was called purity and it was
supposedly based
on this supposedly true murder case
that showed up on this website which is
what is it called true crime no it's not
called true crimes.com it's called like
crimesomething.com and it was this old
website
and there was apparently this case on
there about this girl
named purity knight who was kidnapped
now her sister had been killed
prior to that like had been murdered i
think or had died some other way
hold on before you keep on going there's
something about this case that really
when i first heard the name purity night
my ears perked up because in mississippi
there's a huge clan of what's called
knight families
there's a lot of knife well that's a
pretty common thing yeah it was real
common in mississippi they were
important
they were like they were like [ __ ] from
the uh
from the free state of jones era yeah
you know [ __ ] with oh what's his name
oh [ __ ]
i'm drunk i can't remember dude's name
now [ __ ] um
go away keep going i'll remember his
name yes so let it revolt against the
against the union and the confederacy
because the county that my family came
from
jones county we fought the the republic
the the we
fought the union and the confederacy
they hated everybody yeah it was
newt knight they made a movie about this
yeah newton's called the free stuff yeah
new night and i haven't seen it but
there were nights there were
nights where were [ __ ] a famous
family in our county and my dad was
new nights and was related with nights
and
nights were a trip and you know what i
mean the [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] certain accent and
everything that that goes along with
that whole county if you guys have ever
heard of the [ __ ] the hodge twins
it's these two bodybuilders
and they're kind of biracial looking the
way they talk is is exactly the way my
dad talks and all his friends talk
and it's because
during the civil war there was no
segregation you had
sharecroppers all bred together whether
they were white or black
there was a lot of that going on people
think all these jim crow laws and racial
segregation that happened
after a long time after so people are
very confused about the history of the
south but go ahead
jim jenny go so this case
um so slipknot had a song called purity
and it was supposedly based on this case
that they had read about and they
thought was a real case there was this
girl in purity night in mississippi
and it was this um count was this county
and i can't
pronounce it um where you do you have it
written down
no i don't have a render but it's like i
don't i don't have any what i was
getting at is that the knights were
mixed
or they were mixed going back to the to
the civil war era but go that's why i
brought that all that up go ahead jenny
so um so yeah so he had been reading
about this case and they thought it was
a real case so apparently this girl
purity night had had a sister i think
his name was
ashley if i'm remembering it correctly
and she had been either
like either died or murdered or whatever
and then
this girl apparently got kidnapped
and was put in like a cage and like
kept there for a very long time and then
there was a whole story about
she was being kept in this cage and she
almost escaped because
she had written there was like a little
boy and he'd been in the woods like
where her cage was because i guess it
was like buried like in a box in the
woods or whatever
and so like the boy actually kind of
found her so she was kind of like
you know kind of [ __ ] up but she was
still alive and she wrote a note and
she's like hey you know can you take
this
you know to whoever and it's like you
know have him save me and tell him where
i am and [ __ ]
so then like this boy who's like nine
years old and he wanders off and the
story goes
that like then another guy came and said
oh i'll take the note
to whoever it's supposed to go to and
that guy never took it
and then she ended up dying so this
whole thing
was on this website and it was like
um i wish i could remember the name of
it it's truecrimes.com or something like
that it's been like around for a really
long time
so there was everything was on there
there was like a there was a cop
statement there was like all kind of
like real official looking documentation
those photographs and all this kind of
stuff
so the dude from slipknot whose name
escapes me at the moment because i was
never a big slipknot fan
um but he apparently thought this case
was real and he wrote at least two songs
about it and it was on one of their
albums
so then later on it turned out when they
re-released the album like as a digipack
or something like that
those two songs were not on there
anymore and then everyone started like
asking questions about it
and then it turned out that they had had
to
they didn't have to take the songs off
but
they were asked to take the songs off
because of quote unquote
copyright infringement at which point
people started investigating and finding
out
that this crime that the uh
songs had supposedly been based on was
not a real crime
at all but was a fictional crime made to
look like a real crime
which apparently was the whole thing
that this website traded in
which i guess slipknot did not know at
this point and maybe a lot of people
didn't know that because
like i said like many you know alternate
reality games
the whole thing behind it is that you
want it to be as
realistic as possible so
a lot of people did actually think that
this was a real crime that took place
now the clue that should have clued
people in
was that the county where this crime
supposedly took place
was a fictional county which was created
by
very famous southern gothic writer
william faulkner
now so it was not a real county so
if anyone had looked up the name of that
county at any point
they would have seen that it was a
fictional county that was created by
william faulkner and that
probably would have clued them in and i
think that's eventually what ended up
um you know clueing people in that this
wasn't actually a real thing that had
happened
so this was not a real crime that took
place
and so what ended up happening was that
they ended up having to
i don't think that slipknot got sued but
they got
threatened with legal action because the
website was like hey this is our story
and it's fiction
so you writing a song about it is
copyright infringement
so i think what they ended up doing was
that they took the songs off the album
you know until they could get it all
sorted out i don't know if they actually
went to court about it doesn't seem like
they did
it's kind of a [ __ ] move when you think
it is kind of that's a [ __ ] move i
think i would have let slip not [ __ ]
talk about that well and the thing about
it though is that i don't know a huge
like i said i'm not a huge slipknot fan
but from what i understand
the lyrics of it were pretty generic
because i think he had kind of like
written the lyrics before he even read
that
and i think he just later went and like
named it aft
named the song purity like after her but
the song was just kind of like a generic
murder kind of sound like that couldn't
really be you know associated with that
necessarily like he wasn't using so many
so i don't think it ever went to court i
just think they
took the songs off the you know album
momentary like you know
uh you know temporarily just so they
wouldn't get into trouble but i think
later on they remember correctly the
funny thing about it is that it was
supposedly taking place
in a county or a town this sounded like
it existed in
mississippi but it didn't did it i just
said
yeah two minutes ago yeah that it was a
fictional account
that was made up by william faulkner at
the writer waiting that's right that's
right yeah
and i said if anybody had googled that
they would have figured that out because
it has its own wikipedia page
yeah but uh this was going around here
before wikipedia
so it was harder to find out even on the
web back then
wikipedia came later that's true because
the website that we're talking about
that had all these true crimes about
early internet it was
like 95. i think the website was started
in 95.
so it was like an ur it was a very early
um
arg like unfiction type of thing
so i think that a lot of people who
neces weren't necessarily internet savvy
the way they are nowadays yeah no one
was then
might have yeah might have believed it
because like i said they had
documentation they had official looking
they had names and dates and places and
it's like they had like
official looking photos and official
looking documents that was pre-googled
it was all aol
yeah because like i said that's kind of
the whole point of
those types of games or those types of
you know what they call
unfiction or super fiction or whatever
they call it i just
you know i hate to [ __ ] repeat myself
on the show and everything but you know
when i do repeat myself [ __ ] the
regulars [ __ ] love it
but i've just had such a [ __ ] happy
memories of early internet
you know what i mean because it was it
was like the wild west
and there wasn't as much on the old on
the early internet back then you
remember it
yeah but i i didn't really like it i
really loved it
message boards and stuff it was all
right it was i liked it exciting
at the time at the time i thought i was
in the [ __ ] future man
i thought i was into i thought i thought
i was in a [ __ ] arnold schwarzenegger
movie
yeah yeah i thought i thought i was in
foot i thought i was in a [ __ ]
running man yeah
[Laughter]
yeah ken said i think ken said i need a
refill
yeah i probably did that's because she
does she does and i gotta stir that pot
you do actually um but yeah so
he told me to look into this and i
thought it was kind of an interesting
case and it actually does have its own
at least um
the that true crime website has its own
wikipedia page
and it kind of goes into um
you know who started it like when it was
started like i said i think it started
in 1995.
and the whole point of it which as i
said this is kind of like ahead of its
time i guess
the whole point of it was to like list
true crime stories
that were not real but you wanted them
to be like as real as possible it was
almost like a murder mystery like that
people could solve
but they weren't real cases but i think
that
you know nowadays in 2020 every time
somebody posts a creepy video or like
something that looks like
a serial killer posted this or whatever
everyone is just being like fake
you know what i mean it's like a game
that you're trying to like earth
you know some kind of like viral you're
trying to make something go viral
but i think in the 90s no one was really
that hip to that idea like i feel like
that was kind of ahead of its time
so i don't really blame like the dudes
in slipknot for thinking that that was a
real case i probably would have as well
especially in 1995
so what are you gonna do but yeah that's
i don't even know if that website is
still going or not
but that was kind of like the whole
point of it was it was kind of like
you know uh like the reddit like you
know creepypasta or no sleep or
something like that where you're
supposed to like write the story and
you're supposed to make it seem like it
really happened to you
you know even though it's fiction but
it's almost kind of like
you know you're you're making like a uh
an agreement with like the reader that
it's like i'm going to pretend it's real
you're going to pretend it's real we're
not going to pretend it's real even
though everybody knows it's not real
but yeah so another video i wanted to
show and this was another one that i'm
just that i just like thought to add
um because this one like really freaks
me out
this one is called my sister now
actually maybe i'll wait till tom comes
back because i want him to see this one
um i looked a little bit i think nexbo
uh
nexbo did a kind of a breakdown of this
one and like
looked into because like i said if you
if you really like
args and like really weird um
youtube videos and [ __ ] you should
subscribe to nightmind
and nexbo because which is a nightmare
ex
nightmare expo and uh because they do
like really really in-depth like
breakdowns and they do a really good job
of like
um you know researching the backgrounds
of like where these videos came from and
like who made them and [ __ ] like that
they're really really thorough so nexbo
did a video about this video
which is called my sister and this
actually
i don't even remember when this one came
about because i remember i've seen it a
couple times thank you
but i remember being really weirded out
by this one
and uh so i was kind of curious but he
did a video about this one
yeah this one's just called my sister i
think i turned the volume down
so it looks like this girl that's just
hey i'm trying on some dresses hey i'm
trying a wedding dress
and then like she kind of like comes
over and she's like hey there's my face
isn't it
[Music]
[Music]
and now she's pregnant for some reason
[Music]
the weird thing
[Music]
dog or um like that it was this guy that
was like
this little chubby dude and he had like
a it was mostly a gamer channel like he
was always like
[Music]
kind of a troll so
he
[Music]
so nobody knew where this video came
from
[Music]
and he figures out
[Music]
that's what i'm saying and it's like and
then it just like cuts off like that and
there's like a little logo that's like a
little ghost
i thought i turned it down i didn't it
doesn't even have any video
or any audio on it i didn't think but
yeah people are tripping
i thought it didn't have any audio okay
but yeah so
so this whole thing was like i think
what nexbo came up with was that
this dude that had this gaming channel
was that he was trying to get attention
for his gaming channel
so he made this video in the hopes that
it would go viral that it would bring
other
because it didn't look anything like his
regular he just had like a regular like
trolley gaming channel like a lot of
dudes that age have
yeah but it was just weird that this was
the only video
that he had on the channel that was like
that so
all that he could come up with was maybe
this dude just made this but nobody
could figure out
why he made it or what was the deal with
the faces like why
is these masks were like they looked
like a real face though
so did david get down the bottom of it
no that's all he could figure out was
that
was that this dude must have just made
that made this to like draw attention to
his channel is that a dude or is that a
woman
no one knows with the mask no one knows
it looks like a woman
yeah but you know they had a mask over a
mask is what it looks like that's what i
mean well
yeah let me let me like um let me do it
again because
like yeah i turned the audios all the
way down
but yes i mean it looks like a woman
right it's not like walking like a dude
it's like a woman to me
and i mean when she's again all of these
men look like women to me
oh for [ __ ] sake i just got talked
[ __ ] but yeah yeah i mean it looks like
a real face
yeah but then when it gets really close
it kind of doesn't look like a real face
yeah you know what it was it was hey
stop it pookie pants you stop that [ __ ]
you're making me talk crazy
anyway uh i i guess with the low
resolution video of the time
it's easier to get away with that oh
this isn't horribly old i mean this
video isn't that old
booker you're doing it again i just
remember seeing it a few times and like
because you're not expecting her to take
her [ __ ] face off
you know what i'm saying it's just like
a mask with a fixed smile and
yeah and then there's another it's a
good mask though because it looks like a
real
person i mean until she gets real close
you don't really see anything all that
creepy about it it just looks like a
regular face
and then she takes it off but then like
so hey
you know what see alex is noticing he
says those hips
are pretty narrow in relation to those
well wait look at the hands and the neck
though that might be a guy i think it
may be
i think that's a guy it's a skinny guy
that's what that is
it's possible i think
and he's got two girl masks on yeah
because this end one is like then he
just starts like stretching it out
and those hands those could be dude
hands i don't know it's hard to tell
it start it's hard to tell
i think it's a guy it's a weird [ __ ]
video is what i'm saying
that's a dude yeah i turned the volume
down this time because i didn't actually
when i watched it i didn't think there
was like really loud audio but
i just turned the audio all the way down
actually um sophie said there was a loud
electro funk song playing over there
that's really weird
i didn't think i couldn't hear anything
we couldn't hear anything
yeah pepper is saying that that walk is
a dude's walking
it could be it's a guy it could be a wig
it's a skinny guy with a wig well that
makes it weirder
yeah if anything he's going
to shoot me i'd [ __ ]
yeah who the [ __ ] would make that
[ __ ] weird
i don't know i don't get it yeah it's a
dude check the adam's apple
yeah let me show this japanese subway
one i forgot all about this one
i don't know a lot about the history of
this obviously it's fake but it's
actually
um it's actually pretty good
because apparently the volume is coming
out like really loud on some [ __ ] and
really quiet on other [ __ ]
like for up for end users on youtube i'm
not really sure why
it's not loud on my end like it's really
quiet i can barely hear it but
apparently like a lot of people
so like so this video here like there's
a whole bunch of people
in japan obviously and they're like at
this you know party or whatever
and then i think at some point like one
of them looks over and they see looks
like
this creepy chick like with a big
forehead or whatever and she's like
looking at them
and then like as time goes on um
like creepy [ __ ] happens with this
[ __ ] chick but uh
yeah so this was kind of a good one this
was another one that came up a lot i
don't know what that dude is saying
because it's all in japanese but you
know what i'm saying
what are you looking at are you watching
i'm watching you watching it
yeah you seen it i see it nothing all
that exciting is going on yet
this guy's just saying i don't know what
the [ __ ] was going on man
he's in his suit and everything
yeah somebody's red mage said i think
that my sister video source has already
been solved i vaguely remember reading
it was about
it was from an ad for a japanese company
that makes silicone masks
i had read that as well and that could
possibly be
like it might just be some weird like
viral marketing
ad about those masks although
you would think that people would be
able to find that out easier
because if it was an ad you'd think
they'd want everybody knowing see so
like everybody the table is like look at
that weird chick over there she's like
sitting
over there and she's like super pale i
remember this yeah yeah
it's like it gets better though because
it's like they they see her right in the
restaurant they're like oh that's really
weird like she's just kind of sitting
over there staring straight ahead
like with a big forehead or whatever and
then this guy's like i don't i don't
know what he's saying because i don't
speak japanese but he's just kind of
like what it was like really weird we
were just out seeing like
at the karaoke bar or whatever the [ __ ]
they were and then they look over there
and then that girl's like look she's
still like [ __ ] looking over here
i wish i could like fast forward on this
like thing but i don't think i can
you know what i'm saying yeah and you
see the thing and she's still sitting
and then she like turns and looks at
them
on my tablet my tablet is way behind
your your image there she is that
yeah big old alien head yeah and then
they're like oh okay that was weird and
then they leave
and then i think later on because they
think they go to the subway
station to go home and i think then
like some other creepy [ __ ] happens the
guy's like i wonder what that was all
about look at his hair
yeah we don't know what that was all
about i don't know why that one person
is like
blurred out and the other people are not
and then here's this guy again talking
about it is pookie still back there
did she leave she got bored she got
bored so now they're on the subway
platform and now this guy is pointing
and he's saying
i think he's saying we saw the same
woman
whatever that says if anybody can speak
japanese says we saw the same woman
yeah well i'm just saying i'm just like
extrapolating
because i saw this video before so i'm
just like saying that that's probably
what they said
so they're like yeah and then she's like
standing
yeah she's like standing there and
looking at them and she's waving
check that [ __ ] out and she's like
waving at them hello and she's got like
really big weird eyes right
and then there she goes
down on the track of the train and then
a train hits her
right yeah and they're like what the
[ __ ]
and they're all like freaking out then
he's going down like that i'm like oh my
god and look look look look look
wait where is she she's coming up she's
coming up she's right there
yeah yeah that was [ __ ] that would trip
you out back in the 90s
yeah 2000s early 2000s
now now everyone is a little more jaded
more
true more immune to imagery well when i
well you know because i'm a horror
writer and i'm like really in horror
movies look you can see her under the
train like laying down which is
i thought that was a pretty good uh that
was a nice touch yeah but um
i remember that one but every bit
everyone has seen everything like we've
all seen found footage movies we've all
you know like i said because i'm a
horror writer and i've seen so many
horror movies
it's like really really hard to
show me something that i haven't seen
before something that really bothers me
you know what i mean yeah i don't want
to see real [ __ ]
that bothers me yeah but anything that's
fictional anything that's like
paranormal none of that bothers me
because it's like i'm i imagine 99.9
percent of the time that's going to be
fake and so
it doesn't scare me but you know
i'm still looking for that [ __ ] though
i'm still looking for [ __ ] that's gonna
like freak me out but
yeah yeah there she was she was like
peeking up over the corner you just
couldn't see her like she was just kind
of like
hey what's up papa
i liked that one but yeah so it's funny
i look in the damn
comment section and sophie's the center
of attention tension and
i know i see that damn so if you're
getting all kinds of fans
see that's what i mean that's what we
told you we told sophie that sophie
meets her own channel but she's
too shy and i don't know and she doesn't
want to start her own channel but she
needs to start her own channel
probably you could we could link the two
channels together it'd be like a sister
channel
yeah sophie you gotta do like reaction
videos or something
reaction man people love those yeah
there is
seriously when i was researching this
show do you know
there are more reaction videos to
scariest videos on youtube than there
are actual scariest videos on youtube
there are like people that are just like
watching the videos and like reacting to
them
overreacting i think but you know i
don't
i don't know i don't know your life so
i'm just saying
but yeah so i'm going to go to the
restaurant back in a second okay let's
go check the food
oh yeah okay that's a good idea but yeah
oh i wanted to mention too this this was
kind of creepy i don't have the video of
this because the video is
not very exciting but like the backstory
is kind of interesting
so apparently there was this video that
was posted
and it was on a channel
um that was just called lisa home
and there was only one video on the
channel and the video
was just of like a countdown like just a
countdown clock like in the middle of
the video right
and i think if i'm remembering it
correctly i think it was only
13 seconds or something like that but it
was like a countdown
and like i said it was the only video
like on this channel now the weird thing
about it though
was that in sweden this girl named lisa
holm
same as on the youtube channel went
missing
and then she was found dead 13 days
after the video was posted so
i don't know if like the video had
anything so that comes up a lot too
because
somebody doesn't like they don't know if
like the killer
like or whoever kidnapped her or
whatever like posted a video like a
countdown type of video like when they
i don't know why anyone would do that
but i don't know
the youtube is a weird place i i
remember like
being fascinated by i don't know if like
you guys remember this but there was
like a whole thing about
this channel called what the [ __ ] was it
called web driver torso
and there was like just all these
[ __ ] really weird like
videos of like shapes and like weird
audio and all this kind of [ __ ] people
like what the [ __ ] is that is it like
some kind of code
is it like some kind of whatever and
then it found and then they found out
later on that it was actually owned by
google i think and it was they just used
it as like a test
channel like for testing like video and
testing audio and testing various things
so kind of like all the mystery went out
of it but then later on another channel
called unfavorable semicircle
also started that had kind of similar
imagery but seemed
maybe not owned by google and maybe they
were trying to do like some other weird
[ __ ] with it so it's like i don't know
if anyone's ever
like figured that out but like i said
i'm really into
and i've kind of gotten into it more in
the last year or so i've really gotten
into the whole
arg thing and i've really like been
looking into because i had seen like
marble hornets and all that kind of
stuff but
i i've kind of gotten into a lot of the
more uh
recent ones so um i think one of
i think one of the commenters mentioned
earlier
there's a really good one called local
58
there's not a lot of videos on it but
it's
set up as though
sort of as though it's found footage of
like a local news
channel going back to 1970
but it's almost kind of like i don't
know if it's like an alien invasion
or some kind of like monsters that live
on the moon
or something like that that are like
taking over humans like slowly
like over the decades but it's almost
kind of like that so it's like there's
a really creepy i mean there's several
videos on there but
there's one that's called um contingency
that i think is like the creepiest one
because it's kind of like one of those
old
cold war era um you know tv
like warnings you know what i mean like
you would get like in the event of
something like really bad happening
but this video is set up like that and
it's set up to look like that but it's
um kind of kind of telling people to
that like the us has been taken over by
like
a hostile force or a force we can't
fight anymore and it's like
it's basically implying it's like it's
all over and there's nothing we can do
about it
so it's basically telling everyone to
kill themselves
but it's like it's really really creepy
but like there's the videos are all
different but they're all kind of like
part of the same narrative so i would
like
um if you like like really creepy like
arg type web series i would recommend
that one
um also there is one called
uh hi i'm mary mary which is about
a girl who wakes up in a house
which she thinks is her parents house
but she can't really remember who she is
or what her name is or anything
and so she's kind of like exploring this
house and it's really creepy it was
supposedly based on like some video game
that never got released
that's good also um there's also one
that i think
is called this one's kind of more like a
video game but it's called concluse or
something
concluse something like that it's kind
of similar to sad satan
but it's a similar type of thing there
um also
there's a channel called deeper
which some people have speculated as
maybe
as a real serial killer i don't know i
doubt it
um but if you want to check it out you
can there's a lot of really weird videos
on there
uh that kind of look like something a
serial killer would post
and as far as like uh
you know short films like that don't
make any
like you know claims to be real or like
these are actually just short horror
films
probably i think i mentioned no through
road earlier which is found footage so a
lot of people thought that was real but
then later it came out uh that it was
actually you know a fictional film i
think my favorite
uh short fictional film that i've seen
on youtube
that i've seen is lights out
which is actually kind of one of the
more famous ones i think it's only maybe
five minutes long seven minutes long but
man that last shot
oh so good it's really really good like
the monster they have in it is like
really really creepy looking
there's also one called the bells which
is very good that has like a really good
monster but there's like a lot of really
good short horror fiction and i would
recommend everybody like check some of
it out but i really like lights out
everybody's seen that one i think at
this point
uh the bells is also really good but
there's like a bunch of other ones too
so if anybody knows of any good ones
then recommend them to me because i like
to watch them also
so what else have tom got to say i don't
have anything to say i was checking that
pot stirring it was looking good
yeah just started to [ __ ] simmer get
on there real low you know
try to get some more cooking time in on
it yeah
that's that mexican uh pulled pork
pulled pork filling
i know for you know you're making tacos
and stuff hungry
yeah you want one yeah okay is the show
over
um i suppose well i guess we can like
kind of talk a little bit more but you
know
when the show's over i'll feed you mango
says we all have to go off and make our
own creepy videos for here
everybody should i mean well it's so
if you guys can make it it's so cheap
nowadays
everybody can do it one of the things
that i wanted as i wanted a new
intro and outro song that was sounded
really cool and maybe had sound bites of
us talking saying [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
that'd probably be really fun if you
guys could come up with some intro and
outro music
because man that would take a long time
to like go through well it would
to go through all of our back catalog
and like yeah of all the crazy [ __ ]
we've
said over the years probably really cool
if you were to make a song out of that
or something that would be really funny
me talking you could do like a
yeah just something something like are
you saying some like weird [ __ ] about
cox or something yeah so if we you know
[ __ ] we ought to do a contest
if somebody can come up with a good
intro and outro song that
uses our voices in it for little sound
bites and stuff
that uh we'll use it in the show if it's
any good
that's actually a pretty good idea a
good idea huh yeah
at least we could use it during during
the show you know what i mean
i also want some [ __ ] sound effects
every now and then in the show
like like a laugh track
[Laughter]
that'd be [ __ ] hilarious you know
what i
you know what that's a good idea yeah i
think i would like to have a laugh
like a laugh track everything say
something but the funny thing was that
you could
okay but you could only use it when
somebody made a lame
like a lame joke yeah you put it if
somebody said something
actually yeah
yeah because it would be ironic though
yeah but i make it funnier
ironic [ __ ] and little [ __ ] sound
bites of like [ __ ] ed and lorraine
saying crazy [ __ ] every now and then
and where's that raccoon you know well
that's that one we definitely did
that's one we haven't like we haven't
touched we haven't you know it's really
funny
like i guess we got a new person i think
it was i can't remember her name but i
think it was like a new
uh viewer a new subscriber that we had
and i guess she was watching one of our
newer shows and i guess we had made the
where's that raccoon joke or somebody in
the comments made it we repeated it and
laughed about it
and she said she commented it's like
what the hell is it about the raccoon
yeah so i had to go on and like explain
and explain what the red
like where the raccoon [ __ ] came from
because i forgot that people haven't
been with us like forever
like you guys don't remember that i had
to do it with a series he used to have
on television called
back when they had television back
before cable collapsed it was called
a haunting and uh and it was called the
haunting of summer win was
it was the episode and they had a crazy
[ __ ] in there that killed the
little girl's pet
raccoon because they lost it because
where's that raccoon where's that
raccoon and when they
when he found the raccoon he killed us i
mean that actor just
sold it he sold it yeah
so it's just i want to know where that
raccoon is where's that raccoon
well that's why i mean we loved that
episode so much just because all that i
mean the kid actor and it was like man
said i could you know the kid peeing in
the closet it was just gold
we haven't watched those in a long time
there was so much to mine from that
episode
yeah you know it was old old [ __ ] that
was from the early 2000s wasn't it
i think it was yeah i mean that was what
season two
maybe mid 2000 season three it was one
of the ones i think i bought you the
first
yeah six seasons not all at the same
time
like well the first four seasons came in
a box set yeah so i got you that and
then i got you five and six like
separately because i guess they don't
sell they ended up being where you
couldn't get them on hard copy you could
only download it well that like a lot of
[ __ ] isn't
really especially tv shows that are not
like not real popular
super popular yeah and i feel like you
can watch them like
other places yeah we gotta check on the
haunting and see how that's going
i still have an open invitation for the
for the haunting is that sh
that's just still on right it should be
they said well yeah because you were
supposed to be on there like
for the for that season they offered to
do they offered to do it
um but they they wanted to do interviews
with [ __ ] lois and red and [ __ ]
lois and red were
they they didn't want to they didn't
really want they were like paranoid they
were kind of paranoid and they were
overly [ __ ] paranoid
oh well the family will [ __ ] not
really approve if we do and i'm like
[ __ ] the family they're not gonna know
about the [ __ ] because they were
old people and they thought everybody
watched the tv they don't watch tv
anymore
do you really think nobody would ever
know that your old relatives are gonna
find out
yeah [ __ ] with your old rounds my old
relatives don't watch this [ __ ] show
they don't know what the hell i'm doing
they were like i don't know they would
they you know they would think well
david
they would they would think that we were
in league with the devil
because you have to understand that that
side of that family they were [ __ ]
they weren't religious but their family
was [ __ ] was a quiver full family my
mom came from a quiver full family that
she had nine
like quiver full tm yeah yeah like like
real holy crap
yeah have as many babies as you can
before your vagina like loosens up and
you drop yeah
and that's just gotta be loose by
[ __ ] number three or four anyway i
would imagine
yeah damn but anyway [ __ ] my grandpa
i mean there's some elastic in there but
you know it's gonna give out after a
while
you can't your vagina can't be a clown
car you know what i'm saying it's like a
clown car
whole bunch of clowns coming out you
actually called it that's the way that
family is
my mom's family is a bunch of clowns
[Laughter]
i didn't say that you didn't [ __ ]
called it i just said your vagina can't
be a clown car
you called it you got to space that [ __ ]
out of that [ __ ]
you got to have it yeah you got to give
it time to like snap back yeah
[ __ ] that side of the family was a
trip my granddad on that side of the
family was [ __ ] work for
jpl jeff propulsion laboratory he also
worked for [ __ ]
grumman aerospace designed all kinds of
shippers on the saturn five pro
program [ __ ] he was right hand man to
the [ __ ] shy of iran before the
[ __ ] ayatollah took over
helping with his [ __ ] build his air
force because my
my granddad did all the jet engine stuff
for the [ __ ] f-14 tomcat
he was a [ __ ] genius aerospace
engineer
but it was weird he was [ __ ] he was
half syrian and he
he was a syrian christian and he and his
brothers came out of an orphanage
it was just [ __ ] some weird [ __ ] i
don't really understand how that
happened
i don't know the whole story but
he my granddad was a [ __ ] quiver full
[ __ ] hardcore christian
all right [ __ ] and had like nine kids
his other his other brother was my uncle
ronnie who was a [ __ ] gangster he was
[ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
all right he [ __ ] won california's
largest jackpot and the lottery in the
same month
oh i remember you telling me yeah
[ __ ] he made like 5 million bucks
on the bat back in the 70s man why can't
that happen to me you're not crooked
enough
i guess not he had friends in the gaming
commission he's dead so i can say that
now
okay the [ __ ] joke i guess that helps
yeah [ __ ]
hitting slot machine jackpots and
winning lottos back in those days
[ __ ] had a lot to do with how much
kickback you'd pay back to people
and then my other [ __ ] my other uncle
their other brother the third one there
was three of them was uh
was uh was my uncle [ __ ] was uncle
what was his name
you didn't remember yeah uncle walton
okay uncle walt uncle walton was gay and
uh he wore a little beanie and [ __ ]
was a painter and saw himself as a great
artiste
i remember him [ __ ] i liked walt
already yeah well walton
walton was like uh was like remember on
on a [ __ ]
uh bewitched [ __ ] uh dr bombay
yeah yeah walton was dr bombay okay i
got you yeah
that was my granddaughter i ran a
feeling that was my grandfather's bro
that's cool
yeah so they were all totally different
you know
[ __ ] but it's just so it was a freaky
family it just goes to show genetics
aren't happening yeah
genetics is a [ __ ] hell of a game
uh yeah pretty bad memories yeah elsa
was asking about quiver fall but
somebody
like where that phrase came from yeah
it's a biblical phrase i can't
yeah oracle said it was uh psalm 127
335.
you're fam it's like a quiver full of
arrows you're [ __ ] at the earth to
[ __ ] spread
[ __ ] the good faith which just gave
me a horrible mental picture of you
putting like a little child like in a
bow and
going shooting them to the chuck e
cheese
demographics demographic domination of
the planet
that's what they're trying to do they're
trying to it's a good philosophy if you
want your [ __ ] to [ __ ] dominate just
have a bunch of kids
yeah that's that's their work that's
their whole philosophy that'll work
have as many children as possible as you
can like choke out other um
belief systems yeah and you know what
that's happening anyway because a lot of
secular people are not reproducing at
the rate
somebody was saying if you look at the
numbers [ __ ] in 100 years the united
states will be amish
because i don't think because they're
having a [ __ ] ton of kids amish and
mormon yeah but the thing about it
though
is that you can have as many kids as you
want but will all those kids have the
same rules
will all those children be as religious
as you that's what i'm saying doubtful
this usually doesn't work that way yeah
it that's what i mean so
i don't have the same amount of kids
that you had so well and they do not
necessarily have the same religious
beliefs that you have
either so it's like that's really not a
foolproof strategy
that's what i'm saying and honestly like
really religiosity in general is
has been going down and has been going
down for decades and i really don't
see that it also depends on what you
call a religion
the traditional religions are going away
alternate religions are coming
because political ideology is also a
form of religion
but can have been many books that say it
really starts off with legends
or hero worship legends religion
and then politics that it kind of
[ __ ] goes into that or excuse me
religion philosophy and politics that
kind of goes into that
that's see i don't i don't has evolved
into that
because philosophy and politics serve
the same
serve the same uh [ __ ] what's what's
the word
it's kind of they kind of serve the same
needs as religion does the
willing the need for a moral compass
the need to believe in something it used
to be religion
then it was philosophy now it's it's
politics
well i don't feel the need to worship
any heroes worship and belief
so i don't get on that she likes to
fight over this kind of [ __ ] i'm not
fighting i'm just saying
i don't i don't i don't have the
political no it's just belief
belief and moral compass i get what
you're saying you don't have to like
right yeah politics does the same
thing in terms of moral compass that
religion right that's all i'm just
saying that i don't have that
uh need so you know but i get that other
people
you do you're moral yeah but i'm moral
without any
need for that for politics i think so or
for
any of that type of um i think so
adhering to like particular beliefs or
particular
like uh in particular people not as bad
as some people but
everybody has it everybody has beliefs i
just
well yeah i know that i'm just saying i
don't have like yeah
i'm i'm ominous i'm honest with my with
myself i just make up belief systems
that serve me and i believe in them
yeah because they they're they're
advantageous to me and they help me win
that because for me it's just about
winning i don't care if it's right or
wrong
this is winning that's not good though
yeah but it happens to be that most of
the time
winning usually has a lot to do with
politics
you know what i mean so you tend to kind
of do the right thing
to win in other words to win a lot of
times you have to have friends
you know i mean there's a certain social
thing involved in winning
uh but then i'm like the ancient romans
too
there's a mix you know what i mean you
have to i'm gonna take this [ __ ] back
i'm gonna take this [ __ ] back
to um to count dante
okay you have to be a master of both
creation
and destruction you have to you have to
be yin
and yang you need sun and moon
you know what i'm talking about you have
to restore balance to the force
you know what i mean sure you got to
know what's appropriate
you can't be narrow-minded in anything
you
you don't talk about you need to you
need to see things in a broader spectrum
which means sometimes you gotta [ __ ]
[ __ ] up sometimes you do
you can do one you can create or destroy
depends on the situation
and yeah you can get in trouble but you
but you get killed you can get killed
but that's what life's about we're not
here to get you killed that's what
life's always
you all eventually we all eventually die
that's another shirt
getting killed that's what life's all
about
you gonna die you are eventually gonna
die
anyway all right no actually george most
of y'all are gonna get eaten by bugs
which
other people call it disease it's little
tiny things in you it's like being eaten
by bugs
most of you will die by eating because
you get eaten by bugs
george carlin actually said that's the
whole meaning of life not dying
[Laughter]
i've never seen anybody gain mortality
well then life's meaningless because
everyone dies
well the thing about it though and this
is what i always we're getting like all
existential but that that's okay though
it's the end of the show and we're like
really drunk and we're like three and a
half hours in it's saturday night it's
fun
but like life is
okay from an outside perspective life is
meaningless
but in a way to me that's very
liberating because that means that you
could make your own meaning
anything that you want to be important
is important
you know what i mean you have to make
your own meaning and that's cool to me i
don't i don't want
i don't want meaning imposed on me from
outside or from like a higher power i
don't like that idea
got michael out there saying the force
is fake dude now the force is not fake
the uh the force the force was not
invented by george
george lucas george lucas is borrowing
that from eastern philosophy
it's just yin and yang's but yin force
and yang force
which is the which is uh what happens in
creation and destruction
to create anything you must destroy
something else
like for instance because it's because
energy is
energy is always converted from one
thing to the next
to build a house you have to cut down
trees so you're destroying trees to make
a house that's what they're talking well
if you're making a wooden house if
you're making a wooden house
if you're making a stone house you have
to destroy boulders to make brick or you
have to destroy
sand to make brick everything is is
converted
from one thing into another this
the eastern versions of those
philosophies are very kind of archaic in
the way that they're described and
they're explained in a bunch of
different stories usually had to do with
siddhartha
better way if you want to do is you can
go and go search the german philosophers
i would
like recommend you know uh scopenhauer
you know [ __ ] arthroscope and howard
and then he kind of
he he explains how the essence of
buddhism is true
then later on friedrich nietzsche came
out and said yes the essence of buddhism
is true but there's a different aspect
of it you can look at
you know if buddhism is true then that
means you have nothing to lose
and if you have nothing to lose then
that means you might as well just go
down
fighting for what you want uh what you
want out of life because you have
nothing to lose in the end
you're gonna die and these are all is a
part of the cycle
you can try to figure it out all you
want you can try to think your way out
of it you can
uh watch conan one
john millius that's what it's about
milius knew all about that he wrote
about it you know
they even made a movie about him what
was it the big the big lebowski
was based upon milius but um
he's there there's a certain universal
truths in eastern philosophy
but okay i'm done we gotta eat
we gotta eat that's more important than
talking to these people
is it let's see what's going on with
these people let's see
i'm just saying it's like i don't know i
don't
i guess i have big like philosophical
thoughts and stuff but i think i
you know came to the conclusion a long
time ago that
because i do not believe there is any
kind of higher power anyone that's like
watching out for us
i was kind of like well um you have to
make your own meaning you have to make
your own happiness in life
and you know i i feel like
from from some religious people's
standpoint
they kind of point to like atheists like
myself and they'll say like well you
don't believe in anything so that means
that you can just [ __ ] over other people
but it's like
i don't want to do that i don't really i
don't feel any need to like believe in
any higher power to like prevent me from
doing that i just wouldn't do that
because
you were a person i am a person i
wouldn't want to be [ __ ] over i don't
want to [ __ ] you over
so i'm not going to do that because i
just think that's a bad thing to do
well when you're looking at things from
a christian perspective you have the
[ __ ] first of all the argument that
there is a higher power
and that's not really what eastern
philosophy and what i believe
well that's what i'm saying i'd be more
into like i don't i don't there is no
higher power
we are enveloped within the only power
which is
existence and all the rules of existence
and it's in one of the main things
about existence is will and nietzsche
gets involved in
in that what will is and and nietzsche's
interpretation of what will
is is not necessarily kind of what your
average man's
will is just wanting to do something
that's not really what the will is
the will is the force and it's like the
dark side of the force
and the light side of the forest kind of
combined
there is no division between the light
side and the dark side of the force it's
just
will and some people have more will than
others
some people can navigate through will
and there's also the will of the
universe it's more like
yeah it's too [ __ ] it's too it's more
like
the main condition of life is that
everything imposes on something else
animals eat other animals and then
animals eat plants and plants
compete with one another for life and
nutrients and try to choke each other
out
even inanimate objects try to [ __ ]
over
other inanimate objects by occupying
space
that one inanimate object could occupy
and denies the occupation of the other
inanimate object
everything imposes on something else
so therefore to exist is to be an
[ __ ]
because you are imposing the only way
not to impose is to die
or well you cannot exist to not exist
i kind of interpret that as like just be
as less of an [ __ ] as you possibly
when you start going into [ __ ]
scopenhauer and you start going into
into kind of the effeminate
interpretation
of it kind of like siddhartha where you
just sit there
and other people feed you and they feed
you [ __ ] plants
and then you say [ __ ] it i'm taking too
much from the world i must withdraw from
the world because i'm
imposing stop feeding me and then you
starve to death
and as you're starving you're like [ __ ]
all y'all [ __ ] i can't be a
bitch-ass [ __ ] and [ __ ] over
these plants i gotta die the plants are
more expensive
they're more valuable than me see it
starts going you start going down that
path
and then that's when nietzsche steps in
and other people would step in and go oh
no no no you're overreacting
you're overreacting go ahead and eat the
animals eat the plants go ahead and do
what you got to do
create great things you're going to die
anyway those plants would have died
anyway
the animals would have died anyway it's
all temporary to exist is to impose on
other things
and you're [ __ ] more you're
moralizing
you're moralizing the imposition on
other things when you shouldn't
you know what i'm talking about just
because you impose you're trying to
you're trying to put a moral value
you're trying to put a moral
a moral [ __ ] label on it don't worry
about it everything is imposing
well i'm not saying you shouldn't worry
about it i'm just saying that you should
try to
minimize how much you're imposing on
other people or you could just be a
total [ __ ] and
maximize how much you impact yeah but
i'm not going to then
you're not going to be here long anyway
so i'm just going to take what i want
and then everyone will kill you well
they might
but the thing is is that you don't get
the badge to [ __ ] over other people
until you're willing to be [ __ ] over
by them you cannot be
you cannot [ __ ] get into this in
solid
solipsism where you think that you're
not you know what i mean that you're
immune you can't be like that i think
that's the main problem
with people who are [ __ ] like you
were saying yes like
it's just is that people they don't
realize it well people
that are [ __ ] tend to like well i
can be an [ __ ] to everybody
else but if someone else be an [ __ ]
to them is like an [ __ ] to them then
they get butt hurt about it
the great warriors and philosophers of
the ages have warned against that kind
of thinking they say
for instance a [ __ ] uh um
what was his name the guy uh
musashi masashi says you can't go out
there and [ __ ]
with a sword and go kill people you
can't do that
you can't do that unless you're willing
to die you know if you're willing to die
then you can do it but
but mark my words you will eventually
die well because other people other
people will eventually kill
have consciousness because they also
because they will fight you
and then and they're not just going to
let you run roughshod if you
if you find one enemy and fight him many
times your enemies will multiply
so you have to be prepared for that okay
and don't whine
about it no don't worry about it matter
of fact uh [ __ ] um
musashi says that well musashi said that
you cannot
hand out death to others until you've
reached a point to where you can accept
death when it's handed out to you
without complaint
well that would be nice that people
would actually guess that you're right i
don't really know what he's talking
about
later on came about in world war ii with
the kamikazes
in other words you must you can't fight
or engage in warfare
until you realize that you're gonna die
and because you're conducting warfare
and therefore
you must assume a kamikaze mentality
you know what i mean you can't go out
there and kill people and think that you
you're not
like i said you're going to be killed
accept it right well but like i said
that's kind of a dangerous mindset to
have too because it's like
let's say you have a hypothetical maybe
not even hypothetical so i'm sure
there's more than one that's not like
this let's say you have a serial killer
that justifies his behavior is like well
i can go out and kill all these people i
want because
if i get killed it's okay but he doesn't
because he doesn't get caught
but but they do that anyway no matter
what you think of it that's true
i think it's wrong all right but dudes
like me would kill him if you can get
hands on him but that's just the way
nature is
you know what i mean you can't look at
it in terms of legalistic
terms you know what i mean they're doing
that anyway you can't prevent it well
i'm not talking about it in legalistic
terms
i'm talking about it in fact they go out
and do that [ __ ]
they're evil they go out and do that
[ __ ] eventually they get caught and they
get killed
now they'll kill more people that some
of them kill 20 30 people you kill that
one dude
is that vengeance no not really because
he's still up on you by 20 bodies
you know what i mean yeah but you don't
know how many he would have killed if
you
didn't stop yeah yeah he was killed more
if he didn't stop him that's right so
you had to stop him
um but some people do have to be stoned
the con
oh a lot of people have to be stuck and
then the concept of fairness and this
and that these are human concepts that
doesn't exist in in
in in reality although like i said you
are stopping it because you
think it's unfair so you stop it and
therefore your will becomes
but like i said you can't get too much
of the naturalistic fallacy like oh this
is the way it is in nature so this is
how it has to be but that's because
that's not necessarily the case well
animals do this
animals go out and do [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
they do but that doesn't necessarily
mean that we should do that
no no you shouldn't do it but you have
things that are wrong
sure you know that's a like that's all
i'm saying
if you have a chimpanzee that's
malfunctioning and it goes out and
[ __ ] bites another chimps nuts off
and then [ __ ] starts killing the
chimp females and [ __ ]
he does it but eventually the chimps
might kill it
and yeah and you know i mean it just
happens it's been happening well like i
said
you get to a point where that person's
continued existence
is detrimental to the population as a
whole yeah but it's also similar to a
tyrannosaurus rex running around eating
[ __ ]
the only difference is is that this
chimpanzee's killed its own kind
but in the big picture it doesn't really
matter you know what i mean
[ __ ] because all those but in the big
picture nothing really there you go
that's another thing that i [ __ ] you
can kind of grab but like i said
the only things that are meaning is what
we make of it right the only thing
that's real are things that are always
real
things that are permanent and when you
look at the [ __ ] universe
because everything everything most
things in the universe are a temporary
status
you know what i'm not you know what i
mean right things are temporary
everything is god
that doesn't mean that you can just do
whatever you want or you can like
[ __ ]
do whatever you want to other people you
can just you know what i mean that
doesn't mean that you i mean it does but
there are consequences they do it
there's comments but there are concepts
it's called solipsism you cannot fall
into the [ __ ]
you can't not fall prey to solipsism and
that is
that that's that's a mode of thinking
where you think
only you matter and that no one else's
will will be applied on you
no they're going to be retribution you
go out and do that [ __ ] eventually
they're going to get you well solipsism
is even more
uh you know internal than that it's kind
of like you think nobody else like
no one else exists well basically
everyone else is an npc yeah exactly
exactly that's but the thing is is a lot
of people are like that
and mostly serial killers are like that
they think everyone else is an mcp
and then when it comes their time to die
a lot of them [ __ ]
beg oh no no don't send me to prison
because they think they're [ __ ]
special yeah that's why yeah right
no one's special no not an impressive
passion yeah let's see what everybody's
saying none of us are special but we're
all special
well we're all special in the way that
we're all unique because nobody is the
same as anyone else because all our
genetics are different so that's cool
like everyone's unique but like i said
no one is special in the sense that
anyone is better than anyone else you
know what i mean
yeah other than you know how their
actions
impact the rest of the world because
obviously you know when you've grown up
and you've done some like [ __ ]
you know like serial killers um i would
argue that they are less valuable than
the rest of us because
they're not really giving us any value
are they so maybe they should be taken
out
but like i said i'm trying to say
no i'm [ __ ] gonna go ahead and agree
with mango badgers on this is that
sometimes you got to put a banana in the
tail pipe
it's true sometimes sometimes you gotta
put a banana and tail fight it's all
good
even sophie knows what that is i showed
it
oh yeah that was one of the movie seven
the whole she was here for two weeks and
i think all they did was just watch
how many movies did you guys watch about
20 of them and they were like
educational movies from the past
she was showing her all the books she's
a lot younger than us she is she's about
10 years younger than us i think now
about 20.
20 years she could be like our child or
some [ __ ] like she could be yeah
and so i had to give her like the movies
that could give her
context to a lot of the [ __ ] that
[ __ ] we talk about
well because the thing too is that the
classic movies
well i feel like a lot of people like
even younger people
they know like all the memes and the
references but they've never actually
watched
yeah the movie yeah so it's like it's
always better like when you watch the
[ __ ]
and everyone's gonna agree everyone all
these other channels that are way into
[ __ ] entertainment like midnight's
edge and [ __ ]
comics are pro secrets and all all the
[ __ ] ethan vascover who's doing that
they're gonna tell you that yeah there
are good there have been good movies
made recently there are some movies
yeah they're [ __ ] yeah the [ __ ] tons of
good news there's always good there's
there's new there's good movies in every
area yeah but the golden era was the
[ __ ] 80s man the 80s the 90s and the
70s
that that era man really could have 90s
yeah not so much
that area era of the golden age it was
like there were a lot of firsts
you know i mean a lot of firsts and a
lot of innovation and you had really
good low budget movies that had a long
reach one of them being [ __ ]
um beverly hills cop man i [ __ ] loved
axel foley i loved billboard hills cop
one and two
not so much three four is coming on the
back of [ __ ] uh yeah i heard about
dolomite
yeah man i can't wait to see that man i
loved
my name dolomite was really good that
was a good one so if you got to see
dolomite is my name
yeah you're you'll love that mood also i
should tell you because
uh sophie is also a big fan of mst like
she said her family was like really into
it
the best thing well among the many like
awesome things about msd
is that sometimes like i understand
probably about 95 of the references on
there because i'm a nerd and like
you know i i'm about the same age as
them or only a little bit younger
but the best thing is that watching like
an
old movie like from the 70s or 80s like
or even 60s
and catching a reference from that movie
that they made a joke about on mst and
you didn't get it before that but then
you saw that moving you're like ah
that's what they were talking about
and you can like do that like forever
because they made so many jokes
you know what i'm saying so if you like
see some seeing like older movies it's
just like worth it if you're into msd
because you will get
all the jokes immediately so i'm just
saying
[Laughter]
see what everybody's saying look at the
five rings yeah
what was that movie with an alien chick
that was nude the complete time life
force life force good movie
she was a space vampire yeah we did a
review on that a while back
good movie what was her name uh she
didn't speak english she was an eastern
european chick yeah
and she was like a model real
good-looking girl she didn't speak any
english that's why she didn't have any
speaking lines but that was a good
british
movie it was like mid-budget yeah it
it it looked like a tentpole flick and
it kind of was toby hooper directed that
same guy that did a texas chainsaw mask
a lot of uh kind of spielbergian in a
way
large scope uh it didn't come out
exactly the way they wanted it to come
out the poster wasn't the poster that
they wanted
there was a bunch of [ __ ] that they
wanted they kind of got matilda may
thank you i knew it was
something yeah i couldn't she was
gorgeous gorgeous girl yeah she's a
beautiful girl um
and naked the whole movie yeah and worth
seeing
another one that kind of came out that
was kind of like that was species one
species was good too kind of like i
think uh what's her [ __ ]
name henstridge was her last name yeah
similar in a way
it was kind of like alien but with a hot
chick
that was china wasn't she yeah she was
trying to like try to get pregnant get
pregnant and then
she was trying to like seed herself with
like human
male right sperm and she was like this
gorgeous
girl that [ __ ] went from like the
time
she made straight shots yeah she went
from like a baby to like a [ __ ]
hottie in her 20s in a few days she grew
up real quick
she was trying to get pregnant to
[ __ ] bring out bring some [ __ ]
monsters
i don't remember all the details i had
to see it again but yeah i just remember
her going around trying to like
trying to get like earth men yeah and
gigger made some of the costumes like it
was like something out of alien
pretty i remember that being a good move
they made like a bunch of sequels to
that but i yeah i don't think this
equals here
that era they were
they were making pretty good movies uh
you look at it now they're not quite as
they're not
really impressive in terms of special
effects because there's no cg
but there's something kind of charming
about them now when i look at them
and the editing and the storytelling was
better
um a lot of that stuff could be rebooted
but i'm not sure modern hollywood as
[ __ ] up as they are
i'm not sure they can really do it
there's only some things like i'm only a
fan of like rebooting
if the movie was like a good idea but
not really
um executed all that well to start with
you know what i'm saying well
i'm generally a fan of like just doing
your own way even if you do something
that's kind of like an
homage to that but do kind of your own
story
well they want to redo or they wanted to
it's about two or three years and that
has gone by now so maybe it won't happen
but they wanted to redo escape from new
york
see i'm not a fan of that and escape
from new york really when you look at it
wasn't really well done
all right it was in in its time it was
pretty [ __ ] cool
yeah but you go back and you watch it
today
it leaves something to be desired of
course the crustal's [ __ ] awesome in
it
it's got lee vancleef it's time to
if you really do if you redo it had good
effects for practical effects
kinda you know what i mean they were
kind of convincing for the time
the models and the but it didn't have
enough action in it
that was the problem it wasn't quite
enough the
okay so the the plot of escape from new
york is
generic enough that you could make
another movie that was
like that but not a remake of that
that's what i'm saying
i would like to see a remake with a new
state pliskin
escape from new york uh the time
frame changed cg
homages to the original more action more
danger
r-rated you know a lot more violence i
think it would be awesome
with the snake pliskin moniker i think
it was with
i guess although i don't know like
i don't know i i remember saying that
like you know you remember like last in
2018
when they remade quote unquote suspiria
and suspiria was one of the movies and
i'm like no one should ever [ __ ]
remake this because
it was a very specific time period a
very specific visual style it was a very
spec
it's like why would you remake it it's
like if you made it too different it
wouldn't even be that movie if you made
it too much the same why bother
but when i saw the remake i liked
that they kind of took the same story
but they went in a completely different
different direction with it and i
thought that was kind of cool
even though i don't know if i would call
it a remake exactly because it wasn't
really it was the same story i guess
but i don't know so so much of suspiria
is tied up with the look of it and like
you know the
the set pieces of like the murder and
it's like that much was different
so it's like i don't know if i would
even call that a remake but
that was one thing where i really didn't
want it remade but when it got remade i
was like okay well
you did a good job okay so but you did a
different thing with it
so i feel like the same thing is in
effect
with john carpenter's early movies
escape from new york
is so iconic and there are so many
things about it
even though the story is not really that
original because there were a lot of
movies like that like post-apocalyptic
kind of society's falling apart kind of
[ __ ] like being made at that time
so i feel like you could do something
like that that was like an homage to it
without necessarily being a remake
you know what i'm saying you could get
the spirit of it without being a direct
remake
maybe they're also talking about doing a
silver shamrock movie i brought that up
i said that before already
see i would like to see that actually
yes has anyone done a graphic novel i
feel like somebody should have done a
graphic novel by the way i was talking
about it on another show and i think
this one can't i think it's canada said
that was that ken
i can't see i think it was camp yeah
he said they need a silver shamrock
movie i was talking about that [ __ ]
several months back on another show
halloween three because that seems like
that seems like a deep backstory that
you could really like get
some like [ __ ] you could get some
meat out of that that should have never
been a halloween movie i know why it
happened it worked for me though oh yeah
that was the first halloween movie i saw
i'd reboot that [ __ ] as silver shamrock
and [ __ ] that really you could add a
few twists
on that and if you had the right people
in the project you'd probably make a
cool [ __ ] flick with that
and i bet you a lot of people would come
out and see that
well i really like i love the idea
because they don't really
make a lot of halloween themed movies
that kind of go into the celtic roots of
it yeah i mean i could probably count
on one hand maybe two hands like how
many movies there are about that
so i feel like that's a lot of like
unmined potential you could go
the the uh the mid-summer [ __ ]
direction with all the [ __ ] you know
see you could go that way
i like that yeah yeah with some [ __ ]
shout outs to uh
to um [ __ ] carpenter and the old one
and the masks it [ __ ] crushes your
head and bugs come out
[ __ ] stuff yeah cause i like that
idea yeah it's all kind of stuff
also kill the children in the movie oh
yeah because like i like
children i like that like killing them
they have to be sacrifices be
ballsy sacrifice yeah
look we should go because i smell that
meat cooking i know we're
we've been going almost four hours crap
and i kind of yeah i have to go to the
bathroom i mean this is my third drink
holy crap
i can't believe am i still coherent
you're coherent yeah awesome okay yeah
pretty good that's good that works right
go ahead and like to show people got 58
people on yeah
give us thumbs up everything like that
you know please like the show before we
check out
like share subscribe like you do
but yeah pookie says feed me not eat me
why would you ever eat pookie come on
now
sophie's in there talking
[Laughter]
yeah she said this is definitely the end
of the episode free-for-all
yeah thank you mango thank you flashbulb
for tom to keep his shirt on
what does that yeah i'll keep it i'm
gonna keep that [ __ ] on
hold on
[Laughter]
that wasn't for you mango anyway that's
for the girls
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah we'll be on tomorrow at 3 p.m est
probably talking about well we might
talk about a movie if we're
sober enough to watch one yeah what is
it it's only quarter to nine we could
probably
still i think netflix added a new horror
movie we probably have to watch it
fight right yeah it's going this is a
family show no this is not a family show
where'd you get that [ __ ] idea he's
joking i'm sure
i'm being saying leave the hobby she's
checking lisa
see how it's going all right we're gonna
go eat some
pork tacos or something like that so
remember like share subscribe
remember to go to our patreon page if
you're not a patreon already remember
you can have until tomorrow at noon to
vote on next week's
movie and next week's topic if you want
to do that i haven't even looked so i
have no idea what the next movie and
topic is going to be so you'll find out
same time as me
but uh thanks everybody for dropping by
thanks everybody that commented and
contributed everything like that and we
will see you
tomorrow bye